[Music]
all right
[Music]
all right let me make the mic what's
going on y'all
well what's going on y'all in here early
it's good to see
on a tuesday
let me know how i'm sounding out here
i'm just checking everything out making
sure
i am good deaf mobile what up
back for the dead what up assemble i see
you in there what's going on
what is going on akw cat daddy early
this is good this is good let me know
how the levels get out of talk to the
people
what's going on guys thank you thank you
sir thank you sir
yeah that's what i'm talking about
yeah we're hoping for a fire one man
we're hoping for a fight i want to thank
y'all for the love
tuesday special edition it's good to see
y'all up in here man
god gave me lord fellaini carly into the
viper den brave you all respect me
listen colin is a real one addict's a
bit hot six layer he's a bit hot
he said you're slightly hot maybe your
mic level a little high
is that better yeah it sounds good to me
[Music]
all right so look lord collin has
responded he will be in the room
def singer what's going on he'll be in
the room soon we're just waiting for the
other little
oh man we got lords of gaming.net
editor-in-chief the legendary josh
redding what's going on assemble
everybody's in here feels good yes i'll
let the king loose on the topic i know
what you all want i know that channel
one
you know six they said you're good now
you said you did now i said look we're
going to chill for a minute
the uh like i said colin will be up in
here saul is pulling up which way for
king
and then 5 p.m he's doing i know what
time it is the realm
i'll be back see you out a bit
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if i can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice and invite your
girl to your squadron cause if you don't
give her that
option you're gonna be single player
like siren you're gonna get tossed in
the bushes by king david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's the avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be meto
i know it's my destiny worked a cognito
who cares
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that jew king david still
be the king of the statues
since the juvenile i've been cursed with
a curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in the crucible was it in
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle
on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
to actually take care of uh some super
chats now
okay so yeah guys so uh before i say
anything i want to say
in advance thank you for any and all
support that we get during today's show
but as you know we have to respect our
guest time so we won't be reading
the majority of the super chats i'm
going to read the two super chats that
we have so far
and afterwards afterwards we'll read all
the super chats so thank you so much
thank you
thank you in advance thank you first off
we have
lady boom josette rivera with the 20
super chat regards and much love to the
iop crew i know it's been a while but
wanted to show my support and love
have a great show saludos from mrs boom
saludos thank you very much thank you
and then we have adam
yeah with the ten dollar super chat held
to the iron lords into the lord of the
last stand
empire guys i've been thinking a little
bit here do you think microsoft might
have oceans 11 the games industry
and media here with all of their moves
uh
oh i don't know let's see let's see what
else you guys saw
oh okay we got two more quick they come
here yeah here we go
plan to take a two hour nap a clutch man
with two dollars if you chat plan to
take a two hour nap but iop
plus collin equals not today that's
right and then we have malik tyler thank
you for your support
all right let's get into it all right
here you hear you you already know what
it is and we are
live welcome to the iron lords podcast
and the lords of gaming.net
episode number 203 and it's another
glorious
tuesday and we are back at the round
table on the lord's day
i'm extremely excited about our special
guest and we've got
mlb the show on game pass playstation
game preservation
and playstation now slash ps plus to
discuss so we're gonna get right into it
i want to introduce a lord who in my
opinion represents a unique element of
pure gaming passion
mixed with an intellectual approach to
the games industry
whether it be his informed opinions on
nerd culture or willingness to engage in
respectful debate
this lord always stands on his square
and ultimately
takes his last stand for what he truly
believes it
introducing the chief creative officer
at lilly mo gangs as well as the creator
and host of the sacred symbols and
knockback podcasts the lord of greetings
and salutations
leader of the last dan movement with the
most
iconic g.i joe collection in the game
live from virginia by way of strong
island new york and kind enough to make
his debut
at the realm of the lords my man
lord colin moriarty how you doing sir
i'm very well thank you oh that's very
completely unnecessary no one's ever
introduced me quite like that
it's like i'm about to give like you
know like uh
appreciate you guys thank you for having
me thanks for coming man you are lord
that you do
huge fans of what you're doing out here
man first of all how you been
and what games have you been playing man
i'm good thank you
um so uh games i've actually been
playing wild arms three for like two
weeks for no reason it's a
old playstation 2 role playing game and
um
it's on ps4 like back you know when they
released like a bunch of backwards
compatible games in 2015 and 2016 and i
just feel like playing it and
my girlfriend makes fun of me every
night because i actually can't stand the
game and i just keep getting further and
further into it
to where i can't stop like it was like
oh i put in 20 hours and then it's like
oh i put in 40 and now it's like
you can't stop i mean it's just a
self-fulfilling prophecy so i hope to
almost be done with it because we were
kind of stuck in this space where
nothing was coming out
and so we kind of still are in that
space a little bit and so i've been
trying to take advantage of it but
with really random and and frankly not
very good games
you should have just replayed one again
that that would have oh yeah i mean
wild arms one is is one of my absolute
favorites i it was funny because i
bought this game when i was a freshman
in college as i remember
and i remember it was all coming back to
me as i was playing it i'm like oh i
remember
why i hated this game everything
you know 20 almost 20 years later so
it's uh but no that's that's
pretty much been it i'm interested in
trying out that that people can fly game
out right
but um it seems like there's no reason
to jump right into these games because
they're always broken
yeah so i'll just wait a little while
and then yeah like i said there's
definitely some server issues
in the beginning so you're not wrong for
that mentality at the end of the day
usually that first week right right
attic my my game crashed like ten times
yeah it's like if the network is is
popping
the the system ain't yeah yeah and then
right now i think they're working out
the
kinks with cross play between cross
console is fine
but uh when you include pc right now i
think they're separating steam and epic
for right now
but that's cool so you already know we
got to get this thing going we got the
four horsemen of gaming
those original lords of the rum here at
the round table with updated time
sensitive king i'm on you
if you go long intro
the difficult game conqueror lord of his
own world and the hop
of the young wolf my man lord addict how
we doing sir
doing pretty good uh you know played out
writers i like that uh
and i play i'm playing some octopus
traveling since we're on time sensitive
king
uh i'm gonna end my uh
my intro right now i appreciate you
brother no doubt
and of course we have our most technical
gaming lord the solo gamer lives with a
single player selfish experience
and also the sastradamus the lord of
clarity and lord patriarch himself
what's going on lord sovereign how we
doing i'm doing good i'm trying to enjoy
these last couple of days of freedom
before i have to go back to the grind
you know so
you know sleeping in till like noon
that's a good thing
that's funny we're very unproductive
very unproductive and
that's what i i need to be doing good i
actually got back into uh i wanted to
get back into the outdoors um
i was just being rude because you y'all
was being rude
i was the one person who wasn't rude
sorry i apologize for enough sir
nah but uh yeah playing the otter
world's a little bit um
silky smooth at that 65 patches very
nice
very very nice so i played a little bit
of that and uh watching return of the
king
okay all right shalom salute and of
course we have the incredible hulk of
this
aka the access gamer who
the prophet of xbox king of the statues
there's nothing less than that premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert
movement oh beloved lord king how are we
doing sir
doing fantastic since i gotta be all
hurried and stuffy
i've been playing the ruler boy i waited
for that game for so long and it's so
fantastic
um i'm just digging into the nuances of
the game i like how the game allows you
to explore
um it was it was it was what it's built
to be for me
um outriders nice they should have never
put out that demo
yeah i'm not gonna lie oh really the
demo had turned me off
uh from the terrible pacing with the cut
scenes
the game feels better it feels more
complete yes
you know the server issues of course i
don't think they thought they was going
to get as much traffic
you know as they got but you know 25
million oh is it is that is that the
game pass plug that in
we keep going up by like
you have the live metrics i forget it's
just the fact that you know um
a lot of good stuff is in there and i'm
getting ready to play
empire of the sun i saw my boy playing
it and i
i downloaded vermintide 2 because i
finished vermintide one
like that game vermintide 2 looks like
more of the same just uh more cleaned up
so
definitely want to dig into that but
yeah no doubt appreciate it all right
right now outright is in the building
and of course we have the gaming ninja
himself
the shinobi lord cognito spreading that
really to the roman iop not telling what
you want to hear but what you need to
hear same thing man a lot of outriders
have been playing a lot of it really
enjoying it like the uh
the loudest shooter grind it's just fun
it's just a fun game they've got a lot
of great quality of life improvements to
ui it's fantastic
yes the disconnection problems are there
yes we're not that's a that's a huge
problem it's a huge problem and
hopefully because we're lou to shoot a
veteran's king and an addict
you know not that's off but he's not a
single player guy
but um you know the thing is you you
know the heartaches in week one so let's
let's give them a little
time to sort out the things but they got
something for solve the the what i like
is
the story isn't as terrible as people
are making it actually i found myself
being drawn into the story and the side
quests are
implemented so nicely like
is not intrusive to you and if you go up
to an npc
that has a quest for you story narrative
right there the interaction in between
yeah it's really nice it's really good
what i've let's go
time time last point i'll make is that
you're funny
last point i'll make is that once i
stopped trying to take the story
seriously and realize they're not taking
it seriously then i was enjoying myself
so that that's where i was at with it
but anyway so look uh last word with
ebantis went down with oh we have philip
carla on
fantastic guess he has horrible opinions
on mass effect but i still forgive him
he still says mass effect mass effect 3
is the greatest so i had to shut his
bike off but anyway
but anyway so that's what i got we got
to get into it but um so now we got to
what the lords have been
playing we got to focus on lord colin
his video game system history his
journey in games journalism
and of course what led him to creating
the amazing
last stand media movement so lorcan
let's start from the very beginning
what were some of the first video game
systems you had what got you into gaming
um the nes was my first console and um
my brother's 11 years older than me so
i'm the youngest of four so
i had a great access to old things when
i was too young for them really so i was
born in 84.
my brother already had it i'm sorry 2
600. i'm sorry i didn't mean interrupt
no you could i no
i said you guys i'm the oldest i didn't
get that that privilege
i was i was totally a mistake i mean
there's no doubt about it
you know all my siblings are like 18
months to two years apart like you know
my brother my two sisters and then six
years later
[Laughter]
god knows but uh yeah i had this real
great advantage and it was built in and
so
i was playing games at a very very young
age a former
formidable age with my brother and so
kid icarus is probably the earliest game
that i
remember really playing and i love that
game but you know i ram kung fu on nes
obviously
the mario nes games and um final fantasy
and the
what we knew was dragon warrior and all
that stuff um
so that was that was the beginning uh
was was that era the late 80s
you know mid to late 80s early 90s yeah
absolutely man and he has tremendous
memories man what what a console
it's my favorite stole my favorite
concert classic classic oh you already
gave
it to a question oh sorry no no you're
good you're fired you're in your bag i
love it
always my happening you're good but i
guess my question is as a sega kid i got
a fanboy a little bit
so was there no intrigue on the
genesis ecosystem at all was it any
temptation
yeah there was i mean so um on my
nostalgia podcast knockback we always
bring up the family called the catchers
who are our neighbors and
they had everything they had like the
master system which i had never seen
until like only in that house and then
never again until like you know 25 years
later
like a genus they had genesis and they
had a pc and all that so they had like
all the stuff that we didn't have and we
would trade back and forth then nice
i remember being really in tight you
know first of all i'm a big sports fan
yeah and so genesis was great for sports
games yes
so we used to play nhlpa and madden and
all that kind of stuff back in the day
on that but
i was really attracted to fantasy star
as well and um
so the four fantasy star games but
actually there's a funny story i tried
to
trade my snes at some point like 1995 to
a neighbor
for his genesis and i gave him like you
know super mario world or super mario
all-stars and he gave me shinobi or
something like that and
um and then my our parents got mad and
made us switch back
i think was which i think was like
because like because you know each
parent not really knowing
thought the other kid was ripping the
other guy
he didn't really know that we were
actually quite happy with the deal as it
was
constituted but i still feel like they
kind of kind of did me a favor you know
because i
i wanted it i didn't i didn't want to do
that you know but i
at the time i did but it wouldn't it
wouldn't have been a good choice they
corrected your mistake
yeah it almost reminds me of a sports
trade where the league steps in
what was that the lakers and the kobe
bryant stuff that oh yeah
shout out to lord jameson with the 100
super chat
thank you just drop in the bag to make
up for all the episodes
i've missed live recently salute lords
thank you so much so much man there's
no disrespect to anybody else yeah
there's like 25 people that did drop
uh one we'll get to them later right now
everyone at the end
absolutely so um okay so went from there
obviously stay in that ecosystem
now 32-bit era um any any any
affiliations there did we go saturn did
we did we
did we do did we make any changes or did
we just stay all the way nintendo for
that through that era
it's funny because at that point um i
was such a i'm such a huge role-playing
game fan
we didn't even really i was talking
about this with someone recently like we
didn't really even know
like what games were like this is a
role-playing game this is a certain type
like a 16-bit chibi
sprite based and you saw you started to
see that happen with
playstation we were talking about wild
arms actually before no earlier
after we started and um that was one of
the first games i saw where i'm like i
need a playstation
and final fantasy 7 obviously was the
same so i actually had both
an n64 and a ps1 that generation i
didn't have a saturn
um no one had a siren i thank you for
saying that
thank you for breaking saul's heart
thank you okay i'm gonna go now
your hero has said that the saturn was
not on his radar breaking my heart
no but just ask him which final fantasy
oh don't do it
listen if you're looking for rpgs and
that was his niche because he was
talking about rpgs
the the playstation was the place to go
remember that was our peek into
uh asian culture to to get these games
over here
that stuff that we found cool when we
was looking at
a lot of these uh you know animes and
stuff like that early animes
this was our way in so yeah saturn
wouldn't be that
unless he was a platform or a 2d type of
dude but
yeah you know to his point is correct i
mean saturn had a lot of that but you
had to really be deep into the ecosystem
and and want to import games and see
important games all the stuff that i was
doing oh something i was sure
i mean i have no disrespect i mean
there's like some phenomenal games on
saturday
uh pandering dragon saga of course is
you know
a seminal game but um it just wasn't on
my radar
you know when you're a kid you have
limited money too i was in
middle school and these consoles came
out so i had to make a choice and
and you know i did i have no regrets
about that choice but
saturn was another one of those things
at that time my brother's roommate had
one his name was ducky
and he was a weird dude he had a bunch
of different video games and saturn was
one of them so that was my
intro into into saturn
[Laughter]
playstation excites you now nintendo
still
you got 64. you got these other things
going on obviously i know you said
finances and your age at that time
it was about one so was it a situation
that
you know seeing that playstation
ecosystem that that's solely that great
console
you know was the excitement just bubbled
over with that was the focus
as soon as the playstation one came into
the picture yeah primarily so i
my brother went and got the ps1 that's
that fall in 95.
um this was when i was uh i remember him
coming out of actually
nobody beats the whiz and new york talk
is
yeah we went and got we went there and
and um he was with his
his girlfriend at the time who's his
wife now and um
he had battle arena to ocean den and all
that and at that time i wasn't really
that attracted to it we were actually
still playing snes primarily at that
time we were a year away from n64
all these rumors in the magazines
obviously the internet is just
you know used net yeah exactly ultra64
and so yes um
so when so n64 has some great games but
i still am of the mind that it's a it's
kind of overrated i mean i think that
like there's talk
there's probably 10 or 12 amazing games
on the console
and ps1 has just many many more than
that and so
you can't really compare the two i
almost feel like n64 is at a severe
disadvantage just because of the
technology
but there's a lot of really cool stuff
on the n64 that i love that some of it's
cool some of it's not but it's super
modular the expansion pack and
rumble and all of that and having
different gears that only work depending
on your hardware it's
it's interesting you know what's what's
funny is they talk about
you know oh nintendo wouldn't do this
they wouldn't
make hardware exclusives like they've
been doing this since the n64
like i remember like the the expansion
pack if you bought uh
majora's mask you couldn't play majora's
mask without it like
like it's just a decision right to
separate the base that way uh not not
that interesting because you know who
was doing
expansion packs first yeah sega
can we explain what happened a second
that's their problem don't do that today
but okay so um
you so did you get a nintendo 64. i just
want to be clear yeah yeah yeah i had
this yeah
all right so all right so yeah their
anticipation for their ntx 64 was good
question yeah did you think they messed
up when they didn't go
cd based and they stayed cartridge based
because i think uh cd would have helped
out the n64
as far as other things that they could
have done with the console because
the playstation had a clear-cut
advantage when it was cd based
and final fantasy was like the number
one catch
you know if they would have went in cd
they wouldn't have lost final fantasy
right there's that early final fantasy
vi demo actually that's running on
instagram
yeah and um which is cool like just when
they were showing off ultra64 so you
guys know all about that but yeah
yeah i think it was a catastrophic
choice and i i it cost them
relationships with all their partners
either permanently or at least for a
time they lost squaresoft
at the time which was a huge loss as you
said and they made a choice which and
they were interesting choices when you
think about it they were like we want
polygons and we want load times and ps1
was like we want
space and we want depth and it's kind of
actually now when you think about it
it's like well that's an obvious choice
but it wasn't so obvious back then
because nintendo
we were buying 50 60 70 dollar games on
nes and sps that you can beat
in two hours so when when when they're
going like well
why would anyone want to play a 100 hour
game on n64 but playstation was like
well
we're seeing kind of different evidence
here so hindsight's 20 20. i don't blame
nintendo for necessarily making that
choice but it was a very
proprietary choice let's see do you guys
remember do you guys remember the
pushback
on cd games yes when it not it didn't
even come first
yeah but it was that thing yeah exactly
it was that thing where this is this is
a dead sort of medium it's not going to
go anywhere
and you know how that came about
because all right and this is a direct
comparison because i had the
mvs uh neo geo console
cartridge base remember cog when i went
and i picked up the
cd base uh console and we got it in the
house and had both of them side by side
you know put both uh had the cartridge
and had the cd
right cartridge straight through yeah cd
they had a juggling little monkey and
all remember the [ __ ] animation
yes and in between each fight round
there was a juggling monkey in the
corner yes i remember so
yes anybody coming from that and
and i knew i knew at that point i'm like
oh no
it was a one-time speed cd drive i went
from the turbo graphics with the same
loading time we went from sega cd with
the same load inside
right radio with the same loading time
correct so
you're looking at the loading times and
that
was a big barrier that nintendo didn't
want to disconnect
you know the the player base from so i i
can understand
as uh they want you and because remember
they come from coin ops and stuff like
that
and playing cards and stuff that was
instant so to take that instant
gratification away from the player i
think that was a paramount on their
thing and it was like now we're not
going to sacrifice this
yeah i hear it i mean like i said i
think we had to send 64 joshua and as a
nintendo guy he would say like that was
one of the detriments that he just
couldn't get into the sony
even though graphically fidelity
everything else but i feel like at the
end of the day
regardless what decision nintendo made
the games they made
with that platform changed the whole
ending oh for sure
for sure for sure transformer
i want to be a kind of like that
hopefully yeah he's back oh i want to
which go as uh
colin ness in reference to coming kind
of glossed over uh what kind of what
you're known for from a developer but um
head house handles um yeah you know i
i've seen an episode with you
in uh the legendary maddie plays a lot
of those guys over there dude
oh psp game boy oh
put it to the screen one more time so
put that glorious yeah
this is my one of my reserve ones in
case the other ones died
i got three as well i told people on
sacred symbols for two years to go buy
your vitas because they were going to
start
going up in price and it's everyone's
like well i'm like it's too late now i
mean
yeah um yeah i love i mean i love
handhelds game boy was
like a seminal machine for me and game
boy pocket and game boy color of course
to a lesser extent
game boy advance of course i mean we
just had oh not just that we well just
came out in japan 20 years ago but i
remember in the summer of 2000 2001
getting my game boy advanced arctic
white
yes castlevania circle of the moon um
super mario advanced which was super
mario 2. yeah and i remember so clear
his day getting that because i got it
the same week that i got
a 311 record that came out that summer
so i just have these memories
of that and so game boy advance the
clamshell of course
uh nintendo ds was another thing so when
i was in college i was obviously poor
big fat hamburger
oh yeah yeah i was happy for the
hamburger i swear oh it was
so my friend went to i went to
northeastern and my friend went to
harvard and i had
i had um uh jury duty and
he and i was like in this thing for like
[ __ ] two weeks it was like a civil
case
and uh he lent me his ds i never played
one before and i was just enamored with
it just absolutely i couldn't believe
how cool it was and how good it was
and what a fun that's why 3ds was so
disappointing to me because it was such
a
fall down from the ds you know and the
gta mm-hmm
yeah yeah i was going to say too just
for for jokes purposes oh
the failed ones along the way while game
boy dominated uh
any any idiot experience with the atari
leaks and the uh turbo express
i was gonna say that so the links i
played later we had one at ign actually
and the nomad
um but my friend cody had a game com do
you guys remember that uh
yeah yeah it was like the weird pda but
they had like resident evil on it and
like all sorts of things so i remember
him having that um
but i never really oh i knew someone had
a wonder swan but that's not really
a failure yeah it was it was uh
great in japan one swan was fantastic in
japan
um neo geo pocket was fantastic in japan
i had every
like handheld you know turbo express was
probably the most expensive
hand held that i've ever had in my life
and it was just you know it was just
huge
uh and had a tv tuner um my game gear
game gear you know a lot of them all the
way up
until i really got my hands on that
first
fat pause uh game boy
and i had tetris very simple game
addict's favorite and i i think i played
tetris
because my mother would send me to go
pay the phone bill and you know i'm
sitting in um
bell atlantic that's you know
and the lines were crazy it was damn
they're out the door
so i'm at the line and i really didn't
care because i'm playing tetris all the
way through and he's like dancing in
there and the battery life
was phenomenal on that thing so yeah i i
i get you you know handheld's
definitely bridged the gap for our
gaming to get back to our living room
so i think the switch was a perfect
marriage when it came to that type of
thing
by the way i want to say i mean because
you were talking about decisions
nintendo made poorly
not having a backlit screen was a huge
boon for them i i
it was kind of a bummer on game boy
advance because i remember playing
castlevania under a lamp because it was
so yeah yeah the little light though
you didn't get a little bendy light the
little no it was like a little 15
delay i had it for game boy but like
where it also magnified the screen
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but i love
it you know because
you were saying you know born and raised
in new york and all that everyone that
i've ever known that has had
lots of different consoles and access to
consoles we all come from new york which
i think is so weird
like i think a lot of it just because of
the access to that market
but yeah like the only people i ever
knew that had turbo graphics or anything
like that all new york so yeah
i mean yeah you living in long island
was did you did you ever really go and
kind of hang
out in the city arcade wise and stuff
like that no i mean i did from one so
when i was older
um in the late 90s early 2000s i used to
go into the city primarily to play chess
so my brother used to go into the city
to play games and i used to go in
sometimes
specifically to chinatown because you
guys were saying yes we didn't it's so
funny because
we didn't know how much we were being
imbued with japanese culture like yeah
we just didn't know any better like when
you were playing nes or snes games it
was very rare especially on nes to play
anything from
not that wasn't japanese and yep so you
kind of start when you
go to chinatown and you start seeing all
the videos and all the posters and
everything you start putting it all
together
and you're like wow i am this person i
just didn't know
yeah and so those were pretty
instructive moments for me going into
the city with my brother but
he was an arcade fiend i mean he was he
was crawling all over the arcades i was
that wasn't so much my skin
god she got yeah i mean like you
actually so i'm sorry i got kicked
i have a question because so did you go
to
like uh chinatown elizabeth street in
that area because
anytime we had to get imports or you
know um
because that was a huge scene for us
right right we will go down to um
penguin village
or you know they were now jnl it was
right across the street it was
they they had a war going on so
and because one of the employees
actually worked at penguin village and
something happened he opened his own
store
and that was the greatest thing that
happened for us because they had a war
going on so it was bidding prices and
they see you get ready go downstairs
they're like hey
my friend come come inside so you go
inside and they'll tell you what the new
stuff is coming out and that's how you
know about the japanese saturn and stuff
like
so um did you ever get a chance to like
peruse the
import market yeah so i was i was
probably between the ages of like eight
and 12 during this time so i don't know
exactly where we were
all i remember is going it was it was
just like anywhere in a lot of places in
new york city going down into basements
you know yeah that's what it was behind
me basement
yeah yeah exactly exactly right i know
like one store would be like you know
what have manga that you've never even
seen or heard of and then another store
would have like you know just
bootleg nes games
[Music]
i don't know what you're talking about i
was incredible as a young kid like you
had no idea what the hell was
i mean i had no idea what the hell was
going on because i think i told the
story on one of my shows too that we
actually had a
so the katras as i brought up earlier
yes they their dad had like was in a
business and his one of his partners
went to japan
and they came home with what we well i
didn't even know this at the time it was
fab it was uh on a famicom card shoved
into one of those things that that
was then put into the nes and i was like
oh it was only like 10 or 20 you want to
actually use a ribbon
like a cloth ribbon to pull it out
because it used to get stuck in the nes
wow
um and i was like what the hell in my
mind i'm like oh [ __ ] we were playing
famicom cartridges
on this weird bootleg thing i didn't
even know what the hell it was
it was yeah yeah they were region lock
things and
we learned very early on shout out to
the people that found out eraser was
able to
read the playstation um
how to do workarounds my mother thought
i knew japanese
because i had god final fantasy i think
it was final fantasy iii
for the uh super famicom because i went
and got a famicom i had a famicom and
you know i had a super nes
and i played this game in complete
japanese
and it was just trial and error learning
and writing down okay this is what this
spell is it's the wrong button okay
this didn't heal me you know so my
mother came in and i'm doing
uh i'm doing the job system and i'm
talking to the guy and i'm going to
and she's just amazed how you know
like oh my son knows japanese told my
grandmother
i went with him he was wrong
took it to the next level every time she
came in he was making sure he was
watching like
anime with the japanese songs
boys
so far this is great we got some hell on
top we got some playstation talk gotta
ask
um during that era the uh oh gee xbox
also uh
launcher or that 360 any any appeal at
all
at that time yeah so uh this is when my
finances started to open up a little bit
because i was starting to get you know i
was i graduated high school in 2002 and
went off to college i had a job finally
and all that so
uh so i got a gamecube at launch and i
got a ps2 at launch
so my mom actually you guys might
remember remember when you could not buy
a ps2 at like gamestop or eb unless you
agreed to buy like the 200
warranty and like the controller and
they literally wouldn't sell it to you
unless you like bought it
so she did that for me it was like my
combined you know when you try to
combine christmas and birthday i tried
to do that when i was a kid
and so but i got an xbox in the summer
of 2003 when kotor came out
and um it was because ign i was writing
for ign at the time and they
the more i had the more i could write so
i invested the money for that strategy
got into buying my own xbox and um
at that actually i i loved the xbox i i
i was on xbox live in 2002 and 2003
playing like rainbow six
three and all that yeah yes yes in my
dorm in northeastern we had um what are
they called t1 lines like they're really
someone else yeah i used to host them
and you can imagine in 2002 2003 it was
cool because like we were playing with
people over the
country in the world i guess but i just
had great i don't know great yeah
whatever the [ __ ] you call it
um so yeah that was my favorite memory
of the xbox though is that
i had a i had a shelf in my room when i
was a sophomore and
there was a building going up in boston
next to where i lived and they were pile
driving and the xbox just kept like
shaking and then it literally fell off
the bed and almost killed me and you
remember
how much that thing weighed yeah it was
very heavy
yeah so i'll never forget that as long
as i was like oh my god like
it's better than the death of
experiences
xbox almost took me out oh no that thing
was
no joke yeah man tremendous memories i
remember
uh being one of the alpha testers for
xbox live at that time
just an exciting time right because you
had you know lan parties and stuff with
halo if you did the local area
connection
but then the introduction of xbox live
which was kind of groundbreaking and
stuff like that with uh
just playing online with other people
tremendous it changed the dynamic
because up until that point and i know
you can attest to this because you had a
nintendo 64 with the
first console that you were able to
actually plug in four controllers
you know instead of going to buy a turbo
tap or something
else to you know do that and you plug in
your four controllers you're playing
mario carter you're playing goldeneye or
whatever and you're doing couch co-op
and that was the way that you actually
got a chance to play with your friends
unless you had
x-band uh something like that did you
guys know anyone that had x-band i never
did
i actually yes
you know what it was it you you you had
that connector on top of your outer
genesis one and you had that connector
on top and you had to put your little
33 six uh telephoto wide rj whatever
eleven you put that in
whoever could not be on your phone if
your mom was anybody families on the
phone
your game was lost so in the sports
community
like nba live those type of games like
you would play against people i think
the fighting games had a couple of
fighting games right i think
i know i didn't i didn't test the uh
fighting games i
played nba yeah and there was this one
dude named showtime that i was playing
yes he's the killer i remember
yes so me and him will always have these
heated battles playing
and there's this one day and i'm we're
in the fourth quarter
there's like a minute left and my mother
picks up the phone
right so but i'm playing at night i
don't even know why she picked up why
the hell did you pick up the phone
i have no idea there's nobody to call at
three o'clock in the morning
but i'm the only person up she picks up
the phone and she
runs into my room and she's like dj
there's aliens i heard them
[Music]
i'm like you just broke my connection
what are you talking about i broke your
connection
i'm like what are you doing up bro shout
out to the dial-up modems that
ruin every competitive kid's dream that
x-band
i don't know how how slow were those
games running no it was running fine i'm
not gonna really
yes i mean it was decent for his time i
mean you know
listen my memory oh remember memory is
always
something that's uh amazing yeah right
until you actually see that
nostalgia's crazy but at that time
for me to play somebody that either i
never met or
that is miles and miles away always yeah
it was game changing for me and you know
i invested into that and i was probably
one of the beta testers that they got
the metrics for that and said oh this is
a viability
this is a thing that's when king decided
he was never paid to testing out for a
kid
i agree but but but but go on because
the
the difference now from from my actual
question to you
you did all that turbo tap stuff you got
me all um you know nintendo
you know couch co-op right now you're in
the comfort of your home
and you're playing you got you got your
head set on and you got the super fast
connection
how was that experience like that first
boot up that first
lincoln that first you know experience
how was that experience to you
i mean it was it's incredibly memorable
because my audience knows that i don't
really play multiplayer games
so when i'm pulled into one like i was
with rainbow six three which i probably
played for
hundreds of hours it was just it was
kind of like when i played soldier of
fortune or something on pc for the first
time and i'm like what the hell is this
and i guess i should back up and say
like my first online experiences on
console were really on dreamcast
specifically with like the 2k games like
the 2k sports games yes but they were
kind of limited because i remember being
like i remember playing nba 2k1 or
whatever and
there would just be like text on the
bottom of the screen like people were
typing and then you realized like oh you
could get a keyboard
yeah and all that but with this it was
like you said it was different like
there was a headset on you were talking
to people
yeah it was i remember that was the
first time um outside of like
playstation magazine
and a few other things where i was like
kind of trading email addresses and
aim names with people and it was
revolutionary i mean you can never
i feel so bad i mean i know it sounds
like old man like an old man thing but
there was just this brief period of time
as a gamer when we saw it all happen
and it's gone already like it yeah it
kind of came and then it happened and
then it's
it was if you weren't there you missed
it you know and i feel like that was
that moment for me
i agree don't worry we're just we're all
old bastards yeah we're all
ready
i that to be a king will remember yeah
that was the first game
where when the moment i removed
someone's leg
i was like oh no this is the greatest
game ever it is the best
bad game i think i've ever played in my
life i love that because you can just
you can tear away any part of anybody's
body
it was horrific to play i remember my
mom walked in on me playing that one
time she's like what the hell is
that yeah
yeah that game was dope i mean i i love
that again that was just one of those
random games because it doesn't
it's not really the kind of game i like
but it was the same thing like i love
basketball and so i love basketball
video games and so that was just
attractive to me to play online
but that was just because that was like
the first option so you rarely
even when we were talking about
outriders i intend on playing that by
myself right now so
yeah yeah absolutely good question all
right um did you get a chance to play
because we was playing so calm on the
playstation
and they they they had me hooked you
know um
you know we would jack it up with a play
we'll play at night and you know the
text on the bottom of the screen yeah i
get that stuff
but uh their online uh solution at that
time was pretty decent as well
you know there was a upgrade from x-band
um did you get a chance to play any
playstation
uh early playstation games online yeah
so in in the
i guess it was in the spring of 2003 i
went and bought the the
um what was it it was like the adapter
yeah you put on the back of the ps2 or
whatever
and i remember buying socom with it
originally and then i actually went back
and returned it without opening it and
bought madden
and uh then i remembered i bought madden
every year so it didn't really matter
but then um
then i remembered not being able to get
it to work and so i
there are two items i remember getting
bringing back that were both sony items
one was the the minidisc because i can
get that to work and the other was the
multi-player
adapter for ps2 which i just i'm not
very i'm like a luddite i'm actually
pretty stupid with this technology so
it's amazing that i can get any of this
stuff to even work but
yes that was my experience come on the
ps2 uh multi-attack was it like a
l in a way it didn't have like a weird
yeah like a boomerang yeah
like a boomerang yeah right yeah yeah
and it was like yeah it was like a
boomerang that you would put sideways in
the two countries
yes yes yes i do remember look that's a
bad this has to be we could sit here and
talk all day about this oh yeah i love i
love the days of yours oh yeah this is
the great stuff it's the good stuff man
we got gotta move on a little bit cause
i gotta respect ty but um
yeah i wanna talk about that like you
just breaking in into the industry and
i'm saying obviously
you know going from the you know the
east coast over to the west coast and um
i guess for me actually correct me if
i'm wrong you know you actually
contributed to game facts before that is
that true yeah
yeah um my stuff's still all up there so
people can go find me see moriarty is my
name on game facts
i wrote like 35 faqs when i was in 10th
and 11th grade and a little bit in 12th
grade that was how i
got found by ign later on it was just it
was just a
i always say like there's a formula
right for success and a lot of it's like
luck and timing some skill and all that
hard work
but um that was just a lucky that was a
lucky break
you know because they just found me and
they just wanted my faqs and then
they're like oh by the way do you want
to write strategy guys for us i'm like
okay
so uh yeah so i was a game fax i was a
big game facts nerd
i love game facts huge oh i was a
creature of those forums like it was uh
i was all over the place on there
um do you guys know who rod roddy is by
the way that the guy from from
from um from prices right bryce is right
he used to be like the really
he was i don't know if he was gay or not
but he was really flamboyant and he was
like the announcer anyway
i had a i had a nickname like my alt
account on there was rod rotty
i was happy about that but um yeah i
love game facts you know i'm so happy it
still exists yes
it's a shell of its former self even
when you go there i don't understand
video strategy guys i just don't get
them
um and uh even when you go to game facts
now it's like these really ornate
facts you know like with a color and
screenshots and i'm like no that's not
you just have to use
ascii arts
to be honest with you like when it would
come to certain things like i'll go with
when i get stuck or i'm looking up like
a specific weapon for like an rpg or
something
like what's the best weapon for this
subclass i'm done with this i'm sitting
there
like first thing i'll look up is like a
text format and then if i can't find out
where they're talking about i'm like
i guess youtube's next yeah i mean
i was like a big strategy guy person
back then like if
like i remember i collected like up
until i was like 22 23 i had like
like 200 strategy guys yeah primal thing
about yeah the primer guy and it's a
product like for us
it was huge for us when it came to
fighting games right yeah
you buy the primer guy but the primer
guy would give you
the pre-canned combos and then
you would find it preached basically
guys who approached
talk to him the evil facts
where you have to learn you have to
learn the language of of of the of the
fighting of the fighting
exactly that's where that's where that's
where we learned about distance
yeah about frames where we learned about
all the intricacies okay
okay
yes so in other words you learned
everything of the reasons i stay away
from failure
you know when we print it out and we
would print out a fact
just only on the camera and we studied
and
it was like having a college course yes
and you learned your character and how
much knowledge you retained
dictated how well you would do on
saturdays with us we would get started
on saturdays right
monday through friday we would read our
strategy guide
getting ready for these battles and
practice right
and coming and working these moves to
see if they actually work and i
i will never ever forget i specifically
brought i had a gateway pc shout out to
gateway
and i've purchased a printer and he
asked me
oh okay what what kind do you want and
he's going through i said listen listen
listen
i'm on this website i don't care how
fast it prints out i just need
to print out these strategies
yeah totally see this is how i could see
you guys back in the day
like like someone new shows up there
like he shows interest in any kind of
head-head fighter
and then you're like what character you
like he's like that and then he just
throws study
no no no no that's how it was no you get
beat
and we'll tell you yeah yeah yeah yeah
and the ink was a lot of money
the last point i made i know we go along
and get fast but the last part i mean
you were so
intrigued whenever there was an update
or a new fact was posted
yeah okay guys carla i know you're about
to jump in oh no i was just gonna say i
remember
refreshing f5 every day there was a
thing on game facts that just showed you
what was published that day
and so you would just go and wait and
see what the games were and it'd be like
you know a street fighter or something
would pop up and be like oh
i remember those days very well you know
i i and also i just wanted to throw in
also
going to funko or borders or something
and just straight up looking
at strategy guides yeah because you were
stuck be there all day reading them
i don't remember did um did game facts
allow for people like like wikipedia
sort of to update facts or
was it just on the author of the fact it
was just the author like you literally
use an ftp to upload
text documents and then moderators would
put them up
so this is huge because again last point
was just that i was going to say is that
also
based on the quality like you guys would
get reputation
so it was like wow oh colin's got a new
one whoever that author was
if it like he became a rock star in a
way
you know because of the the authentic
authenticity or just how good it was
they started to get reputation but got
to move over i know we got a lot of talk
about
but so again you get there you get the
break now west coast you don't say so
just looking back at
the ign experience like you know how
exciting was that for you in your career
like do you have fond memories
or has that changed that part of
journalism when you started
no it was a i mean it's definitely
changed but um it was a blessing i love
ign
i don't so much love the what the site
has become but i love what they
they gave me an opportunity they didn't
know me from a hole in the wall people
like pear schneider
tal blevins all those guys gave me their
my shot um
and they didn't have to do that and i
did what i always tell people is i just
kicked the door off the hinge when they
showed me like just a little bit of
light like a photon came through the
door i was like boom you know
i was like whatever i whatever i can do
to be here i'm gonna do it so
i was an intern for two summers when i
was in college they actually offered me
a job
to write for the the associate editor of
the gamecube channel when i was 19 but i
turned it down so i can finish college
and when i graduated they offered me a
job i was actually about to start grad
school
and they offered me a job so that it all
worked out really well and i'm super
grateful for them i'm sad to see what
has happened to games journalism
generally but
um that's not really an ign problem as
much as it's uh
other outlets problem ign is always kind
of i i i don't mean to say it like this
because i think ryan mccaffrey who i
think you you guys
i was just yeah i love ryan as a
personal friend of mine um
great guy with the exception of his work
at ign no one does journalism there and
and
i feel like they're not even really
trying to claim that they do that
anymore i think i was the last person
that worked there frankly that was doing
that kind of work
right and it wasn't paying you know like
it wasn't um
it paid me but it certainly didn't pay
uh sorry
the sun's like going in and out so i'm
getting it you're doing that
it's like shut him down down sorry
yeah i have all natural light here on
the left side
and it'll probably just go up and down
but yeah i was i was very fortunate
and uh very happy to have had an
opportunity to work there just things
changed and
yeah and we saw with greg and others
like we just saw that we didn't
it sounds kind of sad i don't mean it to
sound like this but we didn't really
need them as much as they needed us
and we kind of realized that we can
build our own business
and not be paid menially and all
well that know that that's that's that's
a thinking's man's tool
right you you walk into a a situation
and you attain
as much knowledge as possible for a
situation and then you see
where your ceiling is in that situation
when you see that you've reached your
ceiling
and you feel that you can give more and
you don't think you're compensated in
the manner that you're supposed to be
compensated in
you will seek other interests in in
making your own
it's a thinking man sport right and as
far as your journalism go
um i honestly believe like because you
know his integrity and all that other
stuff that goes along with that
but i honestly believe that times
dictate
pace right and then there's a lot
of times where right now the first
person to get the stuff out now
really gets to accolades right but a
real
journalist even if he's last
your name has to hold your credibility
has to hold he will
still garner the same amount of
attention as the first person
now there's so many new people that's
trying to get that credibility and get
that name
that they forego a lot of things just to
be first
just to build up that area and that's
why i think it worked now
to be honest with you i don't know
that's just my perspective of it
um i don't know if it's that's your
thoughts on it
but what is your thoughts on it because
you already have the credibility
to it so you can already say that
whenever you put something out you don't
have to be first
you're calling right that's yeah it's
kind of true i mean in the sense that
like
people patiently wait when in fact we
inten i i let the defining duke guys do
their own thing
and handle their show the way they want
but on sacred symbols we have a rule we
don't even talk to pr
so um we i haven't talked to sony on the
on the podcast side in more than two
years about anything
you know and we run the biggest
playstation podcast in the world so
um so we're able to do that and then we
don't hit embargo like when return all
comes out
we're not going to have anything in
embargo because we don't want the game
early so we'll go buy it and play it and
then people will patiently wait for us
and we're really honored by that but
it's
it's tough because when i was at ign
they would let me dick off for like two
or three weeks
i'd be like i'm gonna go to naughty dog
and um just hang out and talk to
everyone and
i'm gonna write a 50 000 word article
which i did right about the history of
the studio
but because of my work on podcast beyond
and because ign playstation was so big
that kind of evened out and so they were
like well this is paying for it
he can do his prestige pieces over here
and makes us look good makes him look
good
um but like you were saying with so many
new people coming in and wanting to be
first
and all that it's hard to kind of build
the equity right yes right to say like
i now need to go be editor at large i
want to go to europe
for a month and you're going to pay for
it so i can tell some cool stories
right that will never happen anymore
exactly but when i was at ign
um i mean when i left actually they
offered to make me a
straight up editor at large which was
actually always my dream which was
and for people that don't know editor at
large at a corporation or at a
publication is
right below editor-in-chief and it's
basically the part they just do whatever
they want yeah it's probably
um yeah and that was but at that point i
was like it's too late you know like i
wanted this
last year we're leaving you know so
um so yeah it's i feel bad for the
newcomers because
they're competing in this in this
ecosystem this trite
toxic ecosystem and they don't have like
i said the chance like we said
to build that equity so that they can go
do some daring stuff instead they have
to poke the
hornet's nest they have to create drama
with social issues they
you know racial unrest yes um uh gender
unrest whatever the case might be
instead of just celebrating the products
and telling cool stories you know
yeah and that's what jesse i'm glad you
did that you understand that part
because
a lot of people don't get it that this
is what they're
up against they have great intentions
you know and you know we interview a lot
of people that have great intentions
coming in
but again when you're going up against a
larger name that people
will wait for they will wait for you you
know it's an evolution it's an evolution
of
you're trying to be first and build it
up so i i totally get it and i can see
where the industry goes and stuff like
that but
sometimes i take from their pieces
because you can get
a glimpse into the person
by reading some of the text like you
move away to fluff
you can get exactly what you want from
that person because
you know at largergaming.net we have a
lot of writers there and
i go in and i grab exactly i can get a
grasp of the person from the words
that's
how it's written inside shout out for
the sake of whatever you salute that
oh no
by the way i'll also just you know i'll
just say it it's and it seems like it
i i think it's incumbent on audiences to
support this kind of stuff if they want
more of it which i see your audience
is doing in the chat and that's awesome
like really
i was reflecting to my girlfriend micah
the other day i'm like am i doing enough
to support financially
younger and less experienced people
right like am i doing
the work necessary on the other end i've
been such a fort i've been fortunate to
be
the benefactor so can i also put the
shoe on the other foot and be more
supportive of people coming behind and
not
because people always use that term of
like pulling the ladder up yeah like
i've been here so long that i don't even
know if i can pull the ladder up anymore
but
the ladder's still there it's just kind
of rickety um and you're gonna need a
hand to get up
you know um yeah so i think i need to be
more mindful of that if anything
just by calling go throw the rope down
it's like don't use the ladder that's
broke you're gonna kill yourself
i'll pull you up i got you
again before i go into the next question
no i was just saying that oh
yeah no for real i mean i respect just
the the the thought process on it right
because
listen colin is here time out one second
colin is here we got almost uh what is
it uh
six hundred and yeah please somebody
said get those likes up
listen we don't do it on a tuesday
you know he he giving you his time and
he's giving you a lot of gym you've got
a lot of gems come on now let's come on
so get those likes in there thank you
might as well just read lord jameson's
five dollars if it's
over 600 watching yeah that's like a
perfect transition
you know you actually alluded to as far
as you know one of the reasons for leave
as far as you know
worth and and what you guys are putting
in so i want to get into that section of
your journey and you know one of those
next big steps obviously you're kind of
going independent you and your group of
friends and then
you guys create this amazing you know
kind of funny thing so
i guess my question for you is different
in a sense that did you guys realize the
impact you were making to get at that
time
or was it just like everything's moving
fast like young rock stars and you guys
didn't even realize
what was going on you know what was that
feeling like we
i mean it was scary you know in um we
found it we tech
a lot of people don't really realize
this but we technically found it kind of
funny
under kind of the game over greggy show
right moniker
a year a couple years before we even
left and so
actually in it was in september of 2014
i was at tokyo game show
and we had launched our patreon like
just on the side we had actually kind of
gotten permission to finally
launch our own patreon but we can't talk
about games we were people remember we
were like
fastidiously avoiding game talk from
those game over greggy shows
and then we launched the patreon and i
remember being in japan it was like in
the middle of the night the guys were up
in the day and we were talking on
um facetime and we had gotten like 15
grand
in the first day you know which was like
a monthly pledge and we were like
at that point we're like we gotta quit
um because we're not even
we're doing this not only with one of
our hands tied behind our back our arms
but
both of them i mean so we started to
realize like wow there's
some people are eager and hungry for
this and
there were people that came before us
that kind of you know jim sterling was
on patreon before us for instance
but we were i mean patreon told us
themselves and they still say like we
were the proving ground kind of funny
was the proving ground for patreon
um along with i think lindsey ellis and
maybe a few other people
and so we're really proud of that um now
i'm proud that i built a bigger patreon
on our own we transitioned to that too
but i'm still very proud of that work
that first year 18 months of kind of
funny was
exactly what i wanted to do you know
um that 2015 kind of funny was bonkers
and really fun and unique and different
now it's kind of you know
everyone's on twitch everyone's but it
felt a little bit different and and some
really
we keep bringing up sports which is such
a huge influence on me like i know it is
on you guys
absolutely and i was looking at sports
coverage which i still think is far
superior to game coverage and i'm like
well
there's not even a live show like no one
even does anything on twitch that's
where people
live came from um which was the first of
its kind which i can't believe that was
my idea because i'm i don't really have
my finger on the poles with that kind of
stuff
i feel like what happens with gamers is
that they don't often look outside their
bubble and realize how much better
people are doing things
um both in politics and in sports which
are huge
and so um so we realized the influence
we were having but we were
like you said also kind of flying by the
seat of our pants because we were kind
of making up the rules we had no idea
what the top was
and we had no idea what the bottom would
be and we we all we knew we were jumping
and it was really [ __ ] scary because
we didn't know if it was going to work
listen i you you know that actually it's
interesting to hear you say that because
from the outside looking in it was like
this movement as a collective and it was
new it was fresh and you know it just
looking back again it just felt like
rock stars this all-star team of talent
that gets together
and does something cool so it's
interesting to see how you look back at
that at that time
i wanted transfers because i know with
ty with the first hour but um please
obviously you know everyone knows about
the tweet you know so i have to go into
that nauseam but what i want to say to
you
was that i don't want to deny its
relevance to your story but at the same
time in my opinion
that kind of individual moment doesn't
really define you what i look at it is i
say
it to me gave you the courage in a way
to kind of step out your own and then
establish something
you know completely new like i guess my
question is because
the lords can relate like we came from
something established and then we
broke away right and then we kind of
doing our own thing so
my question overall is ultimately like
how proud are you
of the colin last stand media movement
you know
from that point forward to to what
you've become you know
it's really weird you know it's a great
honor
and people talk about this
you know i hate using um well let me use
a different term
people pretend that they're they don't
deserve their success or they don't
understand their success
and that's real like when i sometimes
when i think about the people that know
me and
we talk and i'm goofy and i'm silly and
whatever like people you know i think
i'm like wow people
really love this [ __ ] um and
we don't really know why other than
that it's authentic and real which is
why we try not to overthink it too much
and so with less stan like it's been
wild because
and you're seeing this i'm very
political and you see this in the
political space a lot with sub stack
um which is a new platform which is
awesome it's a it's a writer's platform
and there's a lot of bubbling animosity
on that side with people that are able
to make the jump and people that are not
able to make the jump and have this
remain with mastheads
and i'm just grateful that i was able to
kind of get away from a masthead at a
website and just explore what i wanted
to do and that the audience was totally
down with whatever
um collins when i was on like i remember
being on rogan
um the first time and being like um
which was which was awesome
i remember crazy look i had to cut you
for a sec but
that was a milestone just to see that
i have to cut that was a moment continue
continue no thank you i mean it was a
completely surreal moment especially
because joe i i met jamie first and then
his producer and then
joe literally walked into the room shook
my hand sat down and we started
recording in about 10 seconds
so that's literally how it goes the
second time i met him he knew me so it
was
it was different but um so i'm just
grateful to kind of be untethered in
some way and to be able to explore these
things and have an audience that
everything out there is free it's like
it's like that really funny
meme where it's like you know support my
only fans and then there's the guy and
it says like
or whatever it's like you can get
anything you want for free anything
and that people go out of their way to
pay like they're doing on your super
chat like they're doing on my patreon
and all that
that's even a bigger deal right because
it's not like they're just looking at an
array of magazines and they have to buy
one
they can say like we can buy a magazine
or we can just go to this website or go
to this podcast or whatever and so that
they're willing to
by the thousands and tens of thousands
like come and support this stuff
says a lot about our content but it also
says a lot about the competitors
in the old space you know yeah and in
fact it's pretty damning
i think i got a question yeah i got a
question
all right let's say the tweet never
happens
right alternate world right what if
universe let's go um
where do you see yourself that tweet
never happens i don't know
my intention would and the guys knew my
name no i know i i know about that
yeah i know about that i just want to
know okay
where do you see yourself like just just
the tweet never happens
the things you're doing now are still
happening right
right you know writing games i see i see
icic
yeah it would have been i wouldn't have
it would have been
there wouldn't have even been a jumping
or reasonable jumping off point to have
any yeah so that's like i totally agree
it's like almost like a chapter book is
being written
yeah yes and from that moment the
inflection point
the until dawn butterfly effect happens
and um
you don't really know what's gonna
happen after that so the funny thing
about it though is it's kind of like a
grandfather paradox because like
the tweet never happening means that i
probably
there's a chance i would have been kind
of funny still you know there so it is
it is it's almost impossible to examine
the new content without that inflection
point because
that was the excuse to kind of start it
to begin yeah so
it's a very philosophical question what
did it teach you about yourself and what
you could do
and and couldn't do and sort of the the
the rough the rough spots that you had
to sort of go through to get there
it was um i learned a lot i mean
i quit kind of funny i think it was it
was something like the 8th of march
and then i launched last stand or what
was colin's last day at the time
march 15th in between that entire space
i had to like create a brand
figure out what i wanted to do get logos
that's not a lot of time like you you
were like
oh all right like that's kind of crazy
if you think about it because that's not
a lot of days
like like you you must have like been i
wouldn't necessarily say like panic mode
but you was like like i gotta really sit
down here and think what i want to do
next
like yeah it was it was it was scary i
mean
i d i i just had a i just have i have a
psychiatrist and i have to see a new one
so i had you know you have to like
explain everything again
and uh and i was telling them i'm like i
deal with my pressure and stress
by doing things so like when the stress
and the pressure is the worst the only
way i can alleviate it
is to actually get the stuff done yeah
so i know a lot of people like
procrastinate and stuff i can't do it
so that seven days or so was
accelerated for to be to be right super
stressed
right but it was important as well i
knew i knew enough about the internet
and i learned a lot from ign from kind
of funny and the experiences there like
you can't wait
in fact i won't say who it is but
there's another gaming personality
that told me afterwards that he felt
like he waited too long to come back in
quotes and it really
injured him his ability to come back and
giving people no time to even
think really before i'm back is was
probably a pretty good thing to do but
um with hindsight because i had a
with hindsight there's a bunch of things
i would have changed but in the in the
storm i i really had
no other options yeah i mean it really
felt it really felt like
you had this in the bag already like it
was like you had this ready to go
and then you know and to hear you talk
about the fact that you just
you know pull all this stuff together in
a matter of a week is
i mean i i'm sweating just thinking
about it like it's it's crazy yeah it
was
something knows your whole story like
and we had covered it a little bit right
but sovereign knows everything like like
when we say he's you're yeah
this is this is so so yeah let me let me
expose these frauds
you know what's funny real quick before
saul does whatever it's all about to do
i i remember like because because what
when i was
in early contacts with you get you on i
was just talking because most of the
time it's me incognito
and then once we have people confirmed
then we go to the other two right so
we're sitting there and i'm talking the
cog i was like i think i got
i think i got i think he's coming on
he's like yeah that's cool i was like i
don't even know how solving king
like i don't even know if they know and
he's like i don't i don't think solve
knows he's like why it's like
because we would know solve notes yeah
but
continuously it's that thing where
when when it happened uh that was my
topic for that week on the on the show
right and some of the reactions like i
was like who's that dude i don't know
like because the thing is what happens
is
it's that stuff where people sort of
stop watching when you sort of into the
youtube thing
people stop watching mainstream media a
little bit like
it just you start gravitating to to to
certain types of messaging and stuff
like that so
it was you know they were like oh what's
going on over there i'm like yo this
stuff happened with with colin moriarty
colin was on you know podcast beyond all
this stuff ign
and it was like the reaction was not so
much of a big deal and i'm like
really like what's good like it was it
kind of
it kind of threw me back because i'm
like i've been following these guys from
from forever and to see what happened um
it was it was very eye-opening for me
and i guess i'll get into my long
diatribes it's
the the opening has come yeah so i might
as well just
yeah you know what i think's crazy part
though like real quick is like
you know we've been doing this so long
like we we have a podcast
from the scenario that we're talking
about like yeah
literally that that's why his story
resonates this year yeah
exactly what what i wanted to say and
this that's the reason why i asked that
question
right because in our situation
we were in a in a situation that
i'm a team guy right right now i can
have my strong opinions all i like but
this is democracy
not a dictatorship and uh
we were in a situation where i felt that
we shouldn't be
in because i believed in us as a team as
the unit as the group
and i know you believed in yourself
right because when when you're there you
you're part of a team but you are this
stronger entity when you look at it in
hindsight
and i felt that tweet was
the catalyst the birth
because being good to be at bad
the tweet came but you fought through
that because
you're uh like you said under pressure
this is the ultimate pressure that
you're going to get at this point in
time
because you're in a position where
you're like you said this is what
it was on point this is where you was at
this was your sweet spot
if that tweet doesn't happen you're
probably still in that sweet spot
because it was very confident
it was very to the point it was perfect
right
so here's the catalyst to make you be
all you can be after that because a lot
of this great stuff doesn't happen have
that doesn't happen
be it good or bad right i'm not either
on either side right
and you can talk to you yeah absolutely
yeah i think that's super insightful i
was just gonna i mean just in the sense
of
um you don't i mean it's so trite but
you don't know what you're capable of
until you're putting positions
and then that's where you go and plus
like where you know how you handle
stress
and stuff like that that method and that
coping mechanism like
if you would have waited a couple weeks
to really like think about it broaden
your horizons
you know you might not have caught it
when it was hot so you know you you was
able to take
you know uh the situation how it was and
he was like i'm about to blow this up
and make it on my end
because a lot of internal strength but
perspective from it so when when we got
into podcasting right
it you know as people who've always
followed games and talked about games in
our circle in our group
there's a certain way you talk about
games you laugh you joke or whatever but
we never talked about games in the way
that we do
on a podcast where you you sort of have
to take the information that comes and
analyze it in a way that maybe you never
did before and it's a whole different
dynamic so that opened my eyes to like
wow okay games could be talked about
in this way um and then in doing that
obviously you know you get a little more
popular you start growing a community
and in that community you see
positive things and you see negative
things and for us we've always
tried to to sort of focus on the
positives i'm
focusing specifically on the things that
bring us together about gaming which is
the games everything else around it
forget about it
so that that's something that i really
enjoyed about what we were doing
but we weren't necessarily we've always
made a point that we're not we're not
going to be
getting to the political stuff obviously
the gamergate stuff happened and we
addressed it
but it was you know addressing the very
black and white issues of
you know these things that are happening
to people in the industry are wrong
not taking aside and and and and
actually being critical of the fact that
oftentimes the people that start soap
boxing for certain
for for issues and things like that
aren't necessarily doing
the people that are hurt by what's
happening justice right because
it becomes an argument amongst
themselves and not an argument about the
actual issue
so we addressed that stuff but i think
what really opened my eyes to something
that was
that that i was blind to before that
is when you when you left kind of funny
because
the reactions internet-wide to to what
happened
really left me disheartened with
sort of the state of of gaming media
at the point um because
it was just something i hadn't seen
before uh
in terms of how people reacted and and
what
reacting in the way that they were
reacting knowing the pull that they have
right
and knowing that these words were
literally causing the downfall of a
person and not
caring about it it was something that
was eye-opening
and disheartening for me in a way that i
was like wow i can't believe this is
happening
so the thing that bothered me most about
you know
what i saw in general in big games media
was this sort of idea that you know
we're not get we don't want to have the
tough conversations with people that
don't agree with me
we're going to talk amongst ourselves
and the people that don't agree with me
are going to get lumped in
with this generalized feeling of of
opposition
right and and we're not going to take
the time to really
really speak to each person individually
who they are and and and and what
they've actually done
to the point that the stuff that was
coming out specifically about you
there were so many things that would
just as somebody who's listened to you
for many years i was like this is
untrue not true right this is untrue and
then there were people that come out and
defend
and then but that that will get the the
defense of you would get lost in
everything else
and i'm just like this is not who we are
like
at what point and and again the the
critical thing for me about the gaming
media is like
as a journalist if you're if someone is
classifying themselves
as a journalist in my mind in my view
your goal should always be to have the
the hard conversations with people that
maybe you don't agree with
in order to get to as close to the truth
as possible right
because nothing is ever 100 objective
everything is told from a point of view
everything has an angle as objective as
we try to be it's never it's never the
case but
at least the goal should be to strive
towards that
and i didn't see that happening and it
really it destroyed
my again and i didn't want to generalize
because there are plenty of of
journalists who don't do this
but it kind of destroyed my my sort of
this image that i have of these
you know these outlets and these people
that i'm following all my life
and and and they allowed this to happen
to one of their own
because for us the idea of ilp has
always been about
inclusive inclusivity inclusivity from
the moment
we you know we used to hang out as kids
and and and
and that it was something that always
brought us together
yeah like that that's supposed to be a
unified a dividing force
it was and it was always about if you
feel like you don't fit in anywhere you
fit in with
us so many people that came into our
group that were just
misfits myself myself i was bullied as a
kid i was bullied i was
your typical overweight pimple-faced
coke bottle glass before you became
pimped out soft exactly exactly yes
early
but i felt always i always felt safe in
this group of
misfits that loved games and they love
pop culture and
and and japanese anime whatever the case
may be and to see
those same people that came from those
same origins
doing this to one of our own it it
destroyed me it really bothered me
it bothered him a lot because he brought
it to us and he brought it to us
it was it was yeah it was it was one of
those things where i just like i cannot
believe this is happening and then
beyond that
just as looking at them as as as
journalists i'm like
one point like check this out if peter
jennings
decided like hey man like i don't like
ayatollah convenient
i don't like i'm not going to talk to
them i don't know like
no that's your job dude like that's your
job
but the thing is this this course
is you can't see fear all right so
all right so people see your aura like
when you come into a room
when you when when when you meet
individuals
right and you've met a ton during that
period of time
there are some people that can peek in
and see the potential of you
if this guy wakes up or if this guy
does this he can be this disruptive
force here and then they start
reflecting on their self to say
where does that leave me right this is
what i never understand about
actual podcasters or stuff like that if
we're all part of a fraternity
right i don't go out of my way to ever
disparage any podcast or anything like
that i don't do all that stuff i don't
actually
i don't i don't have the time for it
because i'm too consumed with what i'm
trying to make us be
and i'm too concerned with planning on
what we should be
because i know we haven't reached our
ceiling and i know there's places that
we can go
uh in this in this ecosystem right
but then there's fear from people that
you don't know
that is watching you what i saw from and
what i'm taking from from this whole
thing was
that they knew that this was an
opportunity of weakness and they felt
like there was time for them to pounce
they did not know how strong colin was
at this point in time and under these
stressful conditions and i'm glad you
elaborated on
what you do when you are stressed be
careful people
when he is stressed he is going
the roundabout way of getting to the
question
yes let's get this
you touched upon it a little bit before
what is your take on
gaming media today where it is where it
can go to improve
and it's this this idea of
sadly that that some outlets or
people whatever the case may be seem to
be
on board with this this cancel culture
which
affects to me how they how they do their
job because we've seen it in terms of
you know people not wanting games to
come out six days in fallujah uh
kingdom come deliver and stuff like that
um
and specifically what they're willing to
do to one of their own
peers um and and also this idea of not
wanting to have the conversations with
people they
don't agree with right do we come back
from this
no um i don't i don't i don't think we
do i i think
there's a lot here right like
the thing about the culture war is that
we all don't want to participate in it
all the time and i think that a lot of
people
that watched me appreciated the game
stuff
but also appreciated that i sounded
different in that when that kind of
stuff came up
whatever it was six days in fallujah but
back in the day for instance
or of course remember borderlands two
girlfriend mode remember how big the
deal that was
um and i wrote about those things from
what you might call a conservative
viewpoint on ign
the thing about it is is that when i was
there that wasn't controversial
it caused a lot of fury and parts of the
internet but
they let me be who i want who they
wanted me to be and
and that was myself and here's the way i
i put it before i answer the question
directly is
you take 20 people at ign or whatever
publication and you say like who's an
rpg fan and maybe some people put their
hands up who's
uh a sports game fan and some people put
their hands up who voted for
donald trump and no hands go up right
now that might a lot of people say like
that's not relevant but that's
incredibly relevant
um because you're writing from things
from for different people
different perspectives different
viewpoints and all those kinds of things
when they came after me in 2017
they and this is the way i explained it
i think it's kind of
100 percent true trump had just won i'm
not a trump supporter but i am a long
islander
they told us that you are they banned us
they said why would we have you on
and we got attacked like please get the
facts right continue
yeah but even even if that were the case
right like even if
i were a trump voter does that
necessarily exactly person like i don't
i just i don't i don't i don't ascribe
to that and
i did a famous video that many people
saw right when i was
kind of funny about the election yes i
remember um where i just said i reject
this and i still four years later reject
the verbiage about most trump voters
just like i reject the verbiage about
far left socialists you know whatever
nonsense i feel like most people want to
just be normal decent people to each
other
and all of that but i was the closest
thing that echo chamber
ever had to a trump voter not even being
a trump voter i was the closest thing
that they ever had in proximity to one
so what happened after he won they went
after me
because i was the closest thing to what
they hated
that they had within arm's reach that
guy voted for mitt romney
you know oh that guy had a ron paul sign
at his desk at ign and he wrote he has a
don't tread on me flag
right um get them you know and you see a
lot of that
over the last four years of people just
taking out political angst
on each other right and it it
infiltrates because it's what you were
saying king and i agree like
trying to create a positive ecosystem
where we can talk about the substance of
the games
and talk about what we love about the
hobby but when you have infiltrators
that insist on putting the culture war
into everything
then you have to be a willing
participant in the culture war and if
you want me personally to be a willing
participant in the culture where
you might not like what i have to say
that's that's going to be the big thing
is that i'm not one of them
right you know and what like all of the
disparity
disparaging thing that things that have
been said about me in the past dude
guys it hurt me a great deal to be
called racist i don't know it hurt me
at my core to be called a sexist or a
bigot or a nazi
yeah i feel you better that really
shook me because it was being
that it all it would have taken was greg
or someone else to say like these things
aren't true
right but when you have no one willing
to do that for you for some reason
then it makes it seem like oh well these
guys are just willing to stab this dude
in the back
so why do we why would we like him and
that that really sucked for me to
experience it still hurts
it cost me a lot of social angst um
but that's what i was saying earlier is
like when i get stressed out when i get
put into a corner
i'm going to [ __ ] you up yeah oh i'm
sorry i'm not supposed to curse
you you've been in your bag this whole
time but we went to let the road bro
[ __ ]
we were supposed to stop you long time
it was so
pure it was so pure in my heart i
couldn't allow
you not to express yourself because
you're getting vip too
the whole thing is yeah i'm sorry you're
good brother you're good you're good
the thing is this is your voice right
and
and it's not on sunday be honest with
you yeah you know it's not the lord i'm
all about that
right but also um
i just want your voice to be heard from
our group maybe
maybe people didn't get a chance to hear
you hear or know the story here
right and they're they're hearing your
voice i want them to hear your voice
you not not yet did i curse like it's
like a sailor so i'm sorry
but it's it's it really
this is why i actually go out of my way
to try to stick up for people even if i
don't really necessarily know them or if
i don't agree with them
um because no one very few people did it
for me and
that was probably the biggest arrow in
my back out of everything that happened
but i still you know it really hurts
i'll give you an example like i live in
a new neighborhood in virginia i just
bought a house here and like everyone's
moving in
i'm i'm kind of afraid of people knowing
who i am
because they're not going to give me a
fair shot if they find if they go
like i have a collins last stand poster
like the original calls i stand poster
in my garage
and i when you open the groud you can
see it from the street and everything
and i wonder i'm like does anyone google
that and then make the connection of who
i am and then
what do they find about me they don't
they didn't get a chance to know me
they got a chance to know all this stuff
about me and imagine if you're
a black man or if you're a woman and you
read this stuff and you're like
wow he's white you know and it's like i
never got a chance
to put my own mark on these people and
to let them know who i really am and so
that's the most destructive part of the
game of telephone and
that's why i will never forgive what was
what happened to me and i'm not a very
vindictive person
in a lot of different ways but i
remember every person
who said something about me or didn't
come to my my i'm watching
definitely and every time one of you
drop out of the industry and fail
or every time or anything like that or
get laid off or need a helping hand or
anything like that i remember
what you did to me you know and i
remember when you came when you came at
me but you slept on my couch for three
weeks
i remember that i left you money but you
came for me i remember that i got you
your job
and you came for me you know and so
that's so i'm not a very vindictive
person but i will always remember that
i'm a very addictive person
like during that whole thing man like
we're i'm part of like a network of a
bunch of different podcasts like
i can't name one podcast that was like
that's validated like every one
podcast i was like yeah cats are culture
on some on some
crazy stuff these days man can't even
make it sweet but
yeah it's just it was just the ex i
remember the hurt
sovereign had that day yeah i really
actually remember it
and um i was like you know because
really i stand
as gamers we stay in our own bubble i
have so much going on
right really literally have so much
going on that if i even get an extra
hour worth of sleep
ever it's a big thing i want to like
have a cupcake because i did it
so it's so much stuff going on that when
he brought it to me first of all i want
to hear what my brother has to say and i
want to know what's going on with him in
fact
and then he explained i was like what
for that
and i laughed because i laughed at the
the
the tweet right brother was like in a
sense because i i was like oh i get the
joke
right i swear we didn't get that joke
you know like whatever
anyway regardless to what um i'm just
like are you serious
but then when you look at it in its
totality
right everybody i mean i've went through
some terrible stuff
and for the individuals that didn't
stand up for me
that didn't talk i didn't know me that
didn't say
oh no who him get the hell out of it
that's bs or whatever
right and i'm not in the that was not in
the internet age
right if you if you didn't stand up for
me i remember just like you said but
totally different i'm totally vindictive
um totally absolutely shut up
[Laughter]
it's absolutely hurtful and you know
like you said you know you go to a
therapist i go to a therapist on
thursdays
and just to talk to get stuff out
because i'm an eternal dude i start to
internalize the stuff and that's
that doesn't work good for you right so
you know you got to get it out you got
to have somebody that you could talk to
that
you don't got to see every day you know
they can know all this stuff and
you know you see them whenever him or
her or whatever anyway
um but this is the cat what i see from
it
because coming not from the magnitude of
your situation
right but just coming from a magnitude
of my situation
certain things needs to push you to grow
to you
fashion and and i see the growth like
you know you said you walked in the room
joe rogan walks in himself how are you
doing boom sits down
and when i talk to these guys and i tell
them
are we going to have x y and z these
type of people on the show and
yeah i don't know king yeah i don't know
you're crazy
yeah you're king i don't know man i
don't know about that one we'll be like
well we'll see you next episode
it took me a while like to you know
obviously
you feel certain stuff about things that
happen and then you you know you stop a
lot of people whatever
and then i thought to myself well i i
have to go back and and
and continue to listen to these to these
other these places because it for me
if i'm if i'm over here talking about
the conversations need to continue
right as angry as that stuff made me i
have to go back
and i have to hope that we can get to a
point
where we can continue to have these
kinds of conversations where
where where you know you know colin
could be on kind of funny one day just
you know whatever the case might be
right right but
the thing is i have to i have to keep
that hope that we can get there because
because the problem seems to be so
widespread and because
this this pervasive this this thing is
pervasive in the culture of gaming
it you know to think that that is just
who we are moving forward
it's it it breaks my heart i got to hit
time on y'all
i know because no i don't know killing
this man when we get to uh the topics
if we get to the time it's better than
the limited time
let's go knowing through yeah i love
this is powerful stuff i don't know what
it means to be disrespectful but i
have to respect colin and your time
because i know i know you got a hard
stuff but
i i do want to drop this first call yeah
in order of uh lord call what we've done
is i went on there and i i bought a
couple of his game codes i'm going to
drop the first one
in the chat right now uh definitely go
try these games out
break up your tools
breakers gonna be the first one so there
it is like it's for xbox
yeah i got two of each so there's three
other codes to give out
i heard that podcast that when you guys
are you you had
you rethought that once what did happen
yeah four paddles
yeah we didn't i mean that's the we
didn't know how hard our games were
again tremendous i hate to be the the
person
but we got to move on but um look again
i just want to say again powerful
powerful story powerful stuff
love what you said solved got above so
what i
listen um so yeah so it was announced
earlier this week that
mlb the show would be coming into game
pass day and date when it releases on
april 20th
and the internet exploded because
how is it that a sony first party game
um is now has
more value on on the xbox platform
as opposed to on the playstation
platforms where people who are who play
on that platform now have to pay 70
dollars for that game
day and day um obviously things came out
about who's publishing the game
and sort of what you know what the
business behind it could have been
but at the end of the day i think we can
all agree that no matter how you look at
this
it's just it's not a great look for
playstation even if they didn't weren't
there's nothing they could do about this
um so
what i want to ask you guys is is
does this open to floodgate floodgates
for other stuff and
specifically to colin like with this
type of move that's happened
that's happened like what the hell are
they doing over there like what's going
on i think i think
you said as much in the tweet like i
don't know who's asleep at the wheel
here but something's going on
yeah that was what was weird about it i
mean so
we knew this was going to happen we knew
the game was coming over right it's not
going to stop on xbox i think it's going
to come on switch next year and all that
and um we knew it was going to happen by
2022 so it happened a year early
but what i was surprised about was that
this
verbiage wasn't in any of the contracts
in other words
how we know mlb is publishing it on xbox
right they're acting as like a proxy so
there's some sort of like layer of
deniability here but how could you have
possibly
had it that your own studio is making a
game ostensibly for free
for your rival and that this is possible
like it in other words like when game
game pass was like well microsoft was
probably like hey can you imagine like
phil spencer or their lawyers going over
them be like there's nothing in these
contracts that say we can't just give
this game away
you know there's literally nothing here
i bet you 20 bucks these are going in
contract from here on out
that's why we got the lord of legality
in the building too
we got the lord we got hold of the
building to sort this out too with colin
folk don't i owe you knees uh for what i
don't even know okay so
um i believe that i told you that i felt
that the series x and the serious time
we gotta keep going
that series x and series x was gonna
outsell the playstation five you gave
those to me already
yeah you did you did yeah okay three
times
you made your payment so you got them
all right cool now continue calling
continue like you said
your point with the uh oh i mean i i
just i'm just surprised that it
was i'm surprised that it was legally
possible it's it's not that microsoft
did it it's that it was possible and i
think sony never thought they would do
something like that
like ever approached in this scenario
yeah exactly so
so the thing i i question about this is
like is there
you know people question like whether
jim ryan knew this and he agreed to this
right or whatever the case means
is that something right as king would
say he's complicit is that something
that's even a possibility here
um yeah it's possible that he knew
but here's what happened all right i
mean i'll just tell you guys clearly
what happened although
i think a lot of people know this major
league baseball came to sony was like
we're giving the game we're giving the
license away to other people
um if you don't publish your games on
other platforms
right so that's what they agreed to do
in order to hold on to sony san diego i
mean that's what they do
um they used to make nba games as people
know and all that but uh
so i think that sony was just put in a
corner where they're like if you want to
keep this game then you're going to need
to publish it everywhere
and otherwise we're going to open up you
know it's not to say that you wouldn't
be able to make yours anymore but we're
going to let 2k
and ea back in and there's going to be a
problem for you
and i think that that's what happened so
mlb acting as an intermediary which they
also do for the rbi baseball games
gives sony some plausible separation
from it and i'm sure rick will have more
insight into this but
it's it's unbelievable to me to think
that this
was possible and i think that this was a
i could be wrong on this but this is
probably a
massive legal error on sony's part and
if anything
um i think we're i'm kind of hoping for
a situation where microsoft and sony
start playing nicer together um
i've often said it would be nice to for
instance get a very customized game pass
on playstation one day
or something with just xbox first party
games or something like that so it
wouldn't cut into the 70
rips that sony are getting on third
party games or the 30 rips i should say
um but i feel like there's something
amiss here and i feel like this
this is such a punch in the throat
microsoft
sony i feel like it's gonna set them
back like if they're really if they were
getting any
if it was getting any warmer between two
very cold rivals
i feel like this is going to make it
much worse and
it's embarrassing i mean this is this is
embarrassing and
there's no way to make it look good for
sony at all it's horrible
horrible situation for them i personally
don't care i've been
even putting it in ps plus it doesn't
fix it well they wouldn't i mean if they
can't
they can't now because well they they
can do it in may but we already know
april's ps plus games so at the very
least
the game will have come out and already
beyond it
the biggest question do you think they
would do that
no because i don't they don't give away
their first party games like that
so that would be pretty unprecedented
they do that with some second party
stuff and some
like they did that with a concrete genie
and some like kind of questionable first
slash second party stuff but giving away
and that's their crash team racing thing
that they had
destruction oh yeah destruction
all-stars but that was just because
they realized no one was pre-ordered
exactly
so i mean that was i was afraid that was
going to happen to eternal so hopefully
that
because i think that game looks
fantastic but the the thing with
the the show is and i don't think people
look at it through this lens is that
it's a first-party game sony makes 100
of the money that they sell so
it's not like they're competing with
microsoft it's not like outriders right
where that's on
game pass or you can buy it right
because even if you buy it on sony's
platform they're just getting 70
of the profit but with mlb they're
getting 100 so
every time they don't sell a game there
it's worse right when they're you know
when
with mlb because they're it's like it's
an opportunity cost
it's not just them losing an outrider
sale it's them losing a first
party sale which is their most valuable
this is a
dangerous shot this definitely broke the
internet
we got the lord of virtual legality in
the realm
my man lord richard hogan of course we
got uh it looks like andrew central's
nicholas downey but he dipped out for a
second hopefully he'll be back with his
zoom call but let's start with hulk man
i'm obviously hulk this news
shaked the internet last week i was
dying i i didn't get that virtual
gatling rival deck i believe you were
traveling well i was i was traveling i
took a week off for pete's sake
everybody
i got some ideas how dare you i needed
that
virtual gallery to get your assessment
so let's get right to it man like what
what did you think about that whole
situation and
and just the like what kind of what khan
alluded to like was it a situation where
you felt like when you see these type of
contractual things with mlb
that was there anything sony could have
done to prevent it this inevitable
outcome that
really didn't look good for the optics
okay well you know
to my eye uh so we knew in 2019 when
this was all announced that the mlb
major league baseball was clearly
putting pressure on sony
to release their game on multiple
platforms this isn't generally something
sony would do on its own
sony views its walled garden hardware as
its primary profit source it's how
it all functions they're not trying to
sell a game pass equivalent as much as
they might try to position
playstation now or plus out there in the
environment to pretend that it is game
passed
so in 2019 we got the first words that
mlb the show was coming to other
platforms presumably to be coming to the
switch
as well what we didn't know until this
past week
was that mlb apparently had the right to
assume publishing
and with that right the right to
determine how it sold on the competing
console
because the worst possible thing colin
is right here i know you know the name
of his old show right
this is the worst possible look for them
because they will have put the money in
to produce this game they will try to
sell it on their platform
uh for 60 70 depending on the console i
assume it's both prices
uh and xbox users are going to get it
for quote unquote free we always use
free
votes but it's the truth sony will have
spent all this money
whatever the deal is with game pass will
presumably trickle
some money over to sony as the
developers but the primary relationship
that negotiation at least as it's
presented right now
is between major league baseball and
xbox
and you can understand exactly how major
league baseball wants this
is that it wants the most eyeballs
playing baseball games it has had
a million giant swaths of the video game
industry not serviced by what is an
excellent baseball game the show is
fantastic it's the best
baseball game out absolutely it is i
mean i got on my baseball cap
baseball game out because continue no
absolutely and so
they wanted to be brought to these
eyeballs they're looking at fifa and
madden and everybody making a fortune on
selling cards
sometimes getting sued and regulated by
governments that don't like the gambling
and they say why can't we have a casino
in our game and
they're starting to move forward with
broadening that appeal
but it is a surprise to me
that major league baseball even though
they were clearly putting it on leverage
that sony you're going to release this
on multiple consoles by it looks like
2021
that they had the capacity to go and
negotiate a separate deal because
when you're looking at this if you're
the lawyer sitting there at sony trying
to figure out how this looks
one of the things you're trying to
protect is if you've got a third party
involved
you want to make sure that they're
incentivized in the same direction that
you are
in order to make sure that you can get
money out of this thing it is a lot
less problematic if the show appears on
xbox for sixteen seventy dollars like it
appears on sony
that's okay we're gonna make more money
we're gonna owe 30
of a licensing fee but you know this is
the same conversation i had in virtual
legality with my viewers about well
there is an example where you could see
microsoft deciding to put something like
star field
on playstation because if it's free on
game pass it looks good for microsoft
anyway they can still make money because
it's their game over on
sony and it looks like they're going in
a different direction
so because yeah you know i do think that
that hybrid kind of solution
is something that will make sense
economically
as microsoft becomes more of that
permanent revenue generating
subscription service and sony continues
to operate in their wall garden
i continue to see i think i just tweeted
this out a couple days ago us moving
towards a kind of synthesis
that once you get over some of the
rivalry here and microsoft kind of gives
up on selling its boxes
specifically in favor of this giant
subscription service
that you might see more of this kind of
unusual pairing and that's my hope
because i think it's great for gamers
but right now with mlb the show
the mlb took over apparently negotiated
a deal for game pass the big surprise
and we have no idea what the economic
terms are there
but it would be a surprise if they're
terribly lucrative to sony and they
definitely kill some of the value
in both the playstation 5 and the people
that might otherwise buy it over there i
can tell you right now
and this is different because it isn't
first party i was going to 100 percent
buy out riders on sony that game pass
announcements comes out and it's like i
would be afraid to buy it over there
that's right
i mean that's a big deal that's a big
deal for square when they're making that
decision it's a big deal to sony
then you take it and you make it a sony
first party right and
it's rare that i look at social media uh
inflammations
and these kinds of discussions and say
that they're worth the hype but this is
a big one
absolutely i have a question i got
something to say real quick
what's the scarf man what's going on
well first of all first of all i got on
my baseball cap
all right right because there's a fly
ball and i'm waiting for somebody to bet
and head it out so i'm catching all
right i got you i got
you okay i just got one more whole
question i got a nicholas
so hulk again i i get everything you're
saying right and you're saying this is
definitely
a publishing deal mlb did on their own
i get it i guess the question i have is
would there be
language that would prevent it from
being on
ps now would there be like an almost
like a non-compete in a way from a from
a service because i guess
the sony fan base the concern was like
okay
if you make the deal with game pass or
whatever like how is it not on any of
their
services that that's the question well
understand sony needs to recoup their
development costs and their business
model is not set up
to get those development costs back with
kind of the nickel and dimes and
playstation plus and playstation now
right microsoft has moved completely in
that direction and put all this
marketing behind it
and is trying to make money that way so
sony looks at this and says
well this wasn't the way we had intended
this wasn't how our budgets were planned
over the last year or two years
and so could they do that it would
surprise me if they can't
um that i think the biggest issue here
was that in between 2019 and 2021
game pass exploded and they're lawyers
lawyers are human beings and you're
trying to anticipate every possible
change in a market and a business model
as you go through these contracts
it appears that they were okay with
major league baseball publishing
but probably not with giving it directly
to microsoft's quote unquote free
netflix type service
and so that changed i don't think there
would likely be a prohibition
on doing a similar thing on the sony
side
but understand in general a third-party
license store is going to have some
interest in how the money comes in
and you're going to have an accounting
to them for the sales of your units
so there could be something that doesn't
make a lot of sense economically with
the sony mlb direct contract that mlb
doesn't care about
because they negotiated their own
contract with microsoft and yes
if that is in fact the case then sony
spent
tens of millions of dollars making a
game that would only be worse served on
their console
that's not great wow okay no i may i
no no chris please colin please yes as i
was listening to mr ho
talk i was thinking of a few things like
the first thing is is that
and and and it's like you said i tweeted
out like because i had this idea right i
was totally wrong i owned it but i had
this idea that microsoft would leverage
playstation
by releasing all of their games on
playstation ultimately from bethesda and
just charging 70 bucks for them yes
being like
70 bucks star field 70 bucks elder
scrolls whatever or you know free or
subscription base here
they took sony's own game
and then did that to them yeah so
it's hard to make there's no because
because you know rick was saying like
even with
um the let's say they got a nice lump
sum from mlb for this which i'm sure
they did
um it's not enough to cover what they're
losing and optically
if they join playstation now and did
that now it would clearly be a reactive
move
like so it would not only be like the
first first party game of any
consequence that would be on ps now
day and day but they would be doing it
in direct reaction but
i was wondering if this is also possible
i wonder if major league baseball went
to them
and was like uh we literally do not care
if you make this game wow because
we want to open this up look what's
happening with ea and 2k
with golf right now that was that's an
interesting place there was no golf game
for a couple of years remember a few
years after tiger woods they did the
rory mcelroy one
and then that was it now there are going
to be two licensed pga tour games next
year
after there being none right for years
and i feel like mlb is looking at this
and being like
we actually don't care if you make these
games because ea and 2k and others are
banging our door down to make this game
here's our lucrative deal to you and
it's interesting that hogue said in 2019
they made this deal i bet if the mlb
went forward
and could do it again they would be like
we don't want to stay with you at all
you can make this game
but we're going to open the license up
so i think the mlb doesn't really care
how sony feels because
they need somebody needs them way more
than they need sony because they have at
least two other publishing partners
that have and would make a quality
baseball game in high heat and 2k so i'm
wondering if that's also in there hot
chick
realizes that she's hot and she doesn't
care what you're doing
i'm tired of this and the other dude was
banging down the door
feel dominance maximus
and i don't care what nobody say this is
the best thing
they can't pivot they can't move like
they can't say
we're gonna put it over here right now
we go it'll be reactionary right
so they can't do that they already told
you what the next move
yeah i was his slate is good respond
don't get to college we can't switch
that up
so the best part of this whole thing is
this is a chess move where you're stuck
in the corner because the next move
might be mate
and this is so fantastic like hulk says
he was going to go buy out riders over
the heat well he was committed
yeah outright is over there absolutely
and then what the field dominance
maximus really is
that's right there you go you're over
here now so i was committed to buy this
baseball game
on xbox as soon as it came out right
when they when they announced it i was
one
i had a whole video lined up i was going
to go on the store i was going to have
he's got
no i got a different video now so and i
was going to go to put it inside my
playstation
and say ah and put it inside my xbox
and turn it up right there this he did
something great for me get home
so here's what i would say i i i think
that major league baseball does think
that um that they
have these other possibilities i will
say
being a big business having a ceo title
next to your name
doesn't make you infallible as much as
talking to some of them might make you
think that they think that and so i do
think major league baseball is pressing
on sony but it is a game of chicken
uh yes it looks like sony has you know
fall into the leverage at this point in
time and they have but major league
baseball also
doesn't want to lose eyeballs the entire
purpose of this
is to broaden the audience and
electronic arts
or 2k or anybody else isn't sitting
there ready with a baseball game
tomorrow
right um also the show is fantastic
and while major league baseball might
think that they are
what would you the hot girl
and they might be they're also dating a
nice respectable man
and those two people that are knocking
down a door say hey we're going to make
this happen
but you don't have proof of it so there
is risk right on every side
because that hardcore secretly be going
to those other dudes
without the other one she's creeping
she definitely told you she over here
for the masses like
the eyeballs is really on this side
she's hiding texture going outside of my
phone
the metrics is dead they know how much
they're going to sell uh
given in this space over here on the
playstation right
and uh to mlb's uh um uh
astute knowledge they said well what
would it look like if we put it
multi and we give you the option we're
gonna go over there yeah of course she
applied pressure she wanted an open
relationship
of course she went over there she
applied that pressure she put it out
there
and you know he was like either you can
mess with me like colin said
either you can mess with me too also but
i want to date others
oh we just don't i just go to everybody
else
she's for the streets now she for the
streets
sony said you know what i agree with
this but what sony did
not agree to was it was for freedom
the game
android central in the building what is
your thoughts on the mlb
thing sir well everyone's done a really
astute job at describing
what's going on from the playstation
perspective so i kind of want to talk
about the xbox side on this one
a bit because that's more of my
knowledge of
vision so to speak and i think it's kind
of really brilliant what they ended up
doing like
obviously circumventing and making the
deal with mlb is probably one of the
i'm not going to say i don't want to use
the term sneaky or underhanded but it's
definitely one of the most roundabout
ways i've ever
seen to you know have a have a good meal
on your enemies uh front lines so to
speak
right um because this is the first
playstation first party game that's ever
been on an xbox console
um but the thing that's most interesting
to me is that
xbox game pass is now kind of
transformed because when this first
the service first came out it was very
much an indie centric
you know your smaller games and your
older games and that was what was kind
of geared towards
and like as someone who likes older
games and indies a lot it really catered
to what i wanted
but we've kind of seen a shift over the
past six months
especially when you start looking at the
addition of ea play
is a very focal point that they're
targeting
everybody with this now because you look
at ea play we've got games like you know
i believe the ufc games in there you've
got the madden game you've got
fifa now you've got mlb basically if you
are a sports guy oh it's just one
of it now yeah yeah if you are a sports
fan
and you don't want to pay a lot of money
to play your sports games
you go buy an xbox series s and you buy
your xbox game pass
and away you go for a very
marginal fee and i think that's a really
brilliant plan
that they've executed and
game pass itself has blown up in such a
way that i would
never have thought the ml mlb being on
xbox is amazing because the mlb games
have been amazing for a long time and
more people deserve to play though it's
a fantastic franchise yeah
um it's one of the best sports games out
there
mlb outs and unlike the madden franchise
improves in a meaningful way every year
whereas madden very feels recycled and
etc
um but to have this game available to
more people and then have it available
on game
pass and you know we put the free
quotations around it
so many people are going to change their
buying behaviors because of that
i have friends that are now like well i
can get the xbox one version so
i'm not going to buy it on playstation 5
because i'll just play it on my xbox one
x now
and it's part of a membership i already
have it's changing
how people approach games and it's wild
good addict
and that's what i was trying to say like
a lot of people
have like i get it like you know when
people ask like look
when it comes to exactly what's going on
with the
you know does sony have to answer a lot
of people say no but like to me
it's situations like this they've
successfully got people that was going
to buy outriders on the other platform
they're buying them on xbox now
now they got the mlb their own game
they're buying it they they're playing
on xbox now then they put their own
first party stuff
they're gonna be playing that on xbox
before you know it p
it's flipped people are no longer buying
a playstation for their sole
practice of playing games they're buying
the playstation to play their exclusives
and they're playing everything else on
xbox
it's like ps3 again and and by the way
i wanna i i was just thinking of this
too i don't know that anyone's really
studied
how much this affects san diego studio
yeah and how it affects
sony's first party because the one major
advantage that i don't think anyone
would dispute is that sony has a massive
quality
uh advantage over xbox when it comes to
first party games absolutely and and the
one thing that i think
is kind of lost in the weeds with the
bethesda acquisition and that 2019
gobbling
of studios that they did as well is that
they have bad they can't manage all
these studios i think microsoft
microsoft can be in a position where
they can get off a triple a
game every two to three months after a
few years if they get everything going
or
they're gonna be in a situation where
they're closing a third of their studios
because they're not getting games out
and
i don't know how that's gonna work but i
do know that san diego studio
is in a little bit more peril today
because they make
a game that sells five six seven eight
million copies a year
and i've been there many times those
guys are really dedicated to it
famously their producer has a mattress
on his floor in his
in his office because he never leaves
and so some law firms i know
exactly and san diego studio also
cleared out a bunch of their other teams
i mean these the guys that made
guns up and all you know all that kind
of stuff that no one cared about
and there's the rumor of course that
they and they are making games down
there
um presumably an uncharted game so
um it kind of imperils like their whole
objective with that studio and they
don't have as many
bullets in the chamber um you know they
have maybe two or three big ones a year
if they manage everything right and i
feel like this means more
um than people are letting on for that
ecosystem and the outriders thing is
really
interesting too because sony has two
hits this this first uh
four or five months before returnal to
make any money
and the first one is mlb and the second
one is outriders wow
you know and now they have no way to
make any you know
uh heavy gaming revenue apart from their
back catalog so
i don't know that people are looking at
it's the total xbox
is completely owned sony i mean there's
with the situation there's no
doubt but i think people are not looking
at at it deeper because
hogue's right like where they wanna mlp
wants to court sony san diego they make
a great game
they've made great sports games since
their 989 you know kind of heritage
stage right back in the day
um but they but i
and i do but i do agree or i disagree in
the sense that if they were like
we can stick with you or we'll just go
to ea and 2k and maybe they'll get their
games
ready eventually but we're gonna now
just hit a bunch more people in other
words
they're paying their licensing fee on a
flat probably a flat basis to sony per
game sold or for access
but if they're just selling more games
and they don't care who's making them
and i think that's why a lot of a games
have been creeping in specifically with
rbi baseball where they're trying to
kind of hit it from the other end
right and then somewhere in the middle
you know i used to play the 2k baseball
games in like the mid-aughts
and they were okay they were okay but
they went yeah they went to show
they were pretty kind of where they want
to get because i think what
because what would be really even more
interesting is if they opened it up and
then you got a sega
ea nfl versus nfl 2k versus madden thing
where people start really selling games
at different prices and then san diego
studios in a lot of trouble
so i feel like this is more perilous
then maybe people are letting on and we
won't know how it
settles out until we see the sales data
and the sales data is going to be more
muddled than ever this year
yeah if they beefed up their team to to
make these multiple copies but
because it was i mean it was sort of
strange to me that they never talked
about
you know outsourcing to make these other
versions no they made them there
and they made them all there you want to
hear something really interesting i mean
this is another thing that people
haven't really considered sony san diego
a first party team had
xbox dev kids before
long before the consoles were even
announced you know as
you know so there's a there's a lot of
interesting
insider stuff here it was the same thing
like when i used to go to insomniac to
like write stories down there
when they were making sunset overdrive
we didn't know at the time i was there
for resistance three or four fuse or
something but
they wouldn't even let me on that side
of the building because they were afraid
that i would see the xbox consoles and
the minute you saw an xbox console yeah
something was up um it's kind of a
similar thing and so i'm always
fascinated by that like when did they
get their dev kits like
there's a lot of fascinating stuff i
wish i knew a little bit more i think
they made it clear
ramon russell always does a yearly thing
with ryan to talk about the game
over on ign and and you could tell this
year when any time ryan asked him how
difficult it was
on his face you could see it like well
we turn around this game in nine months
every year so imagine now having to make
multiple versions of this same game
right and you could tell
that there was a weariness to to him
um and it's it's it's crazy because
again
you you if you run the studio into the
ground then what happens
yeah i don't it's it's really gonna
that's the thing is that like they have
this one
box they can check every year they've
been checking it since the ps2 and psp
days with nba
inside and all that kind of stuff like
these guys have a game every year that's
really important
and yeah let me ask you a question
really quickly
um so if the game sells uh on a
xbox platform sony gets paid right yes
all right so jim dance moves ryan is
compliant right he's complying here
because you have
x amount of people that's inside game
pass right
and i'm calling for everybody in game
pass to download this game
now let's say half of those people get
hooked
to this wonderful game and that and the
quality of the game is phenomenal
let's let's not you know go past that
let's say
half of those people or or five percent
of these people
purchase this game because it does just
because it's on game pass doesn't mean
you cannot purchase the game right
i outright purchase games after i try
them i like them i'm buying them
right you buy this game
the studio i think the studio will be in
great shape
if they sell whatever they're going to
sell on the playstation platform because
you have those
the playstation people over there that
i'm buying the game over here regardless
i don't care what it's doing in game
pass right right right i'm inside mine
they're married to that ecosystem
right i'm buying my games here so those
people are accounted for that stuff gets
paid for over there
now let's say they make a huge profit
over here
doesn't that bolster and boost the
studio up
opposed to the the uh thoughts of it uh
having an adverse effect yeah it could
be the other side of the coin there
right
certainly but i think it's the same
thing when people talk about microsoft
and how
like the bethesda deal right six and a
half billion or whatever they made that
back in their profit the next quarter
yeah so they
but that came from like azure and all
that stuff right so it's all kind of
mixing up and i think it's a similar
situation where i think sony's happy to
make some money but i think
there's an opportunity cost to lose like
sony's exclusivity is all they really
have and i'm one of the guys by the way
that um i haven't said over and over
again i don't think ps5 is remotely
worth having right now like i know a lot
of people are out there like
trying to buy one i don't think it's
worth i don't think it's worth it at all
i mean maybe returnal and ratchet are
going to
change this i think it probably will i
said in june yeah but
i i feel like to me there
i'm a sony fan i love playstation i do i
do the most listen to playstation
podcasts in the world and i'm telling
you don't buy a ps5
because what's the point right now but i
feel like there's a lot of people like
that so you're talking about like yeah
there's a bunch of people that are don't
care where the game is going to be
they're going to buy it on playstation 4
playstation 5.
but i think you're looking for those
edge cases because right
and this is why i think microsoft maybe
missed an opportunity of
like the star field stuff on playstation
we don't know what's it looks like it's
not going to happen but
you have to eat around the edges right
and
then the pie gets smaller and smaller
and before you know it it's like
it's like a supermarket that runs like a
five percent margin if you if you lose
like a few customers something yeah
i'm really dire and catastrophic and
remember playstation had a hardcore fan
base that even went out and bought ps3
in 2006 and 2007
to the tune of 13 15 17 million people
um and it wasn't enough
to it took me years to turn that around
i'm afraid that sony is entering a
similar situation because it's very
hard to turn a ship and i appreciate
what they're trying to do with their
first parties
but they're going to need more and so
losing
a first-party game essentially at a time
when you're when your competitor just
bought a massive publisher it's i i
don't know if we're going to see king
how it plays out for a few years but i
wouldn't be surprised if sony was much
more cages
about showing their sales figures for
this game which they usually aren't
right and also how much licensing money
they're going to lose on xbox because
exactly
because they're getting a little bit of
a rip for every game pass subscription
no one really knows how it works
we want to get our game our stuff on
game pass and then maybe we'll tell you
we'll probably be mda from doing that
but i'm kind of curious how that works
too
but just the game being on game pass is
so injurious because they're missing the
thirty percent rip
you know so let me ask you a quick
question i know time is limited and i i
want to oh yeah
i know so the question i have for you is
the way i've been looking at it and
everybody's making fantastic points is
it almost feels like a paradigm shift as
far as
next-gen warfare where as in the past
you know we've seen sony aggressively
make these third-party time exclusive
deals or outright exclusive
you know deals to the platform whereas
it looks like microsoft is attacking
with game pass almost day and date and
if we could say there was one achilles
heel
to game pass initially besides their
initial uh xbox game studio first party
it was that third party would usually
come at a later date older in the life
cycle so my question to both of you is
that
you know if microsoft continues to be
aggressive as we're seeing
with an outriders as we've seen with
this mlb the show deal we've even seen
things like octopath
you know traveling which was a dead date
but the gist of it is this diverse
kind of picking and choosing of these
powerful kind of third-party games
you know what does sony do to kind of
try to combat that
because that seems like an aggressive
approach as far as opposition i just
wanted to
ask colin and hogan before calling yeah
you don't mind if i jump in first please
please um
so i think i don't want to underestimate
what sony's doing the whole
why buy the cow when you get the milk
for free i totally get it right like
go around and do second party deals or
timed third party deals and it's safe
it's very safe to do that it's very safe
to go to blue point say like make demon
souls it's very safe to go to square
enix and say like here's 50 million
dollars
we want final fantasy 7 remake for a
year right something like that or 25
million
whatever they're offering up these are
safe deals but by investing in studios
ip uh pipelines and all those kinds of
things you
you get fruit later that's how we got
naughty dog making
uncharted and last of us because they
used to make like rings of power
yes you know and way of the warrior
and sucker punch making you know goes to
sashimi they used to make sly cooper
yes and and sony used to really be
involved and they did this with
insomniac where they would say like we
want to work with people first then we
buy them right so they did this with
insomniac sucker punch
naughty dog and then they make studios
from the ground up which i actually
think is what they're going to do and i
think that there are going to be a few
announcements
to that effect in the next year or so um
including maybe
finally acknowledging that there's a
team in san diego working on a game
so another game other than mlb so i
understand their approach but microsoft
is going to start flooding the zone to
such an extent
that you can't possibly survive um doing
this and so i think first of all i think
jim ryan is on the clock
yeah i think i think he's so wrong um
about so many things that you can't help
but look at his leadership and then i
think
the other thing is that they're gonna
have to turn around and start making ps
now into more of a competitor
because um microsoft's achilles heel
with game pass is that they can't
possibly be making
any money on it in fact i bet you
they're losing catastrophic amounts of
money on it and that's the one thing
that
uh i keep trying to tell xbox fans like
microsoft is probably losing
billions and billions of dollars on game
pass
but they don't care yeah
sony does care remember that playstation
3 almost killed
sony yep you know it almost killed the
company
so unlike xbox where it's just a thing
that i own microsoft stock
no one really cares about xbox when it
comes to microsoft money
right everyone cares about playstation
when it comes to sony money
and so they can't play around and so
they're in there i don't want to say
they're in trouble because they're the
market leader as far as we know still
but
this stuff will settle out soon and it's
i don't think it's going to look great
for them i just don't
phenomenal hog your response and then
i'll uh
yeah no accept that response they'll
call it i accept that response
that's all i've been saying and everyone
keeps telling me
attic you're being too much addict they
don't have to do nothing i'm like
look i can't tell if you can't see down
the road if all you see is fog and water
that's not my fault
i want to say real quick in a battle of
attrition sony loses
100 of the time so uh so you can't
they have to do something so anyway yeah
no they're not remotely the same size i
mean that's a point that i bring up in
in my videos and i have i think on this
very podcast which is that
if you're not thinking microsoft as just
a trillion dollar company
you're not getting the scope of these
two these two
industry leaders even though you love
video games microsoft has so much more
going on it's not even close
um i will say this uh while microsoft
can find the money in the couch cushions
to buy bethesda
and i think they're going to continue to
do that with further acquisitions i i do
think there are things sony can do i
think sony is coming to the realization
or they should be that
there really is a market for a recurring
revenue subscription service and they
better start thinking about
exactly how they want to uh position
themselves in that market now in my
perfect world
i would be acting behind the scenes to
figure out exactly what a relationship
with microsoft looks like
to get some version of game pass on the
playstation because i really do
think that you can much like this
particular situation
undercut in some important ways your
main competitor
by changing the exclusiveness of what is
going to be their primary premier
product
and if you have that availability on
your box effectively you're the box to
get
because you have your first party you
have whatever god of war 3 looks like
you have game pass with some
accessibility
and if you do it right microsoft doesn't
ultimately care
if they're making money from that bigger
audience they don't they aren't
evidencing a strong interest in selling
boxes under the tv
so it's a matter of getting their math
to work and colin is exactly right in
saying what i've said for a number of
years which is that
the game pass math couldn't possibly be
working right now
right this is a what we might consider a
marketing effort you know we just saw
let's say disney plus increasing their
rates by a significant percentage 15
percent
across the board game passes right now
in the gain eyeballs gain eyeballs day
nine balls and if they weren't microsoft
you would see this for what it is in
terms of a startup just trying to get
subscribers never being revenue positive
and trying to get bought by microsoft
you know say maybe a discord type
company and microsoft's doing that right
now
as effectively a startup game pass being
a startup model
where you put all this stuff out you put
all this capital in you get all this
investment
even though it's self-investment on the
hopes that you can spin it around
and the big question mark for me is when
effectively the two or three years of a
dollar of game pass runs out that deal
i everybody that i've talked to is on
that for game pass right now i'm on it
from when they essentially allowed you
to
upgrade your xbox live gold and just get
game pass for free
for a dollar for the rest of the time
period when that clicks over
and they actually start asking for
fifteen dollars a month what they're
trying to do right now is prove the
value proposition so you say
i'd be stupid not to but everything
changes when they start to figure out
what that population looks like when
they're not running ridiculous deals
and when developers and publishers start
to get more and more analytical data
about whether the deal that they made
with microsoft for game pass was a good
one was a smart one
because all of these are bespoke you
know i think colin and maybe yukon said
hey
what are these deals even at game pass
everything that we've read
suggests that they are different for
everyone yeah that's what i'm here for
the triple a to double a to single lay
to indies whatever it might be
and that takes an enormous amount of
analytical resources and some people are
going to have gotten burned
and some people are going to be making
out like bandits but it's a very
arduous timely process and
it's a question mark about whether or
not everybody's going to be willing to
enter into that deal the second time the
third time the fifth time
when microsoft actually looks to turn
this into a profitable division of their
company
because right now they are not and yes
every publisher should be jumping on and
taking all their money and saying thanks
oh my god we're eager lily most eager to
do
this
let's go and that's exactly what should
be happening but we
it still hasn't turned that corner right
and there have been companies
that never turn that corner and i i
think game pass will i think they've got
a smart direction i think they're
eating playstation's lunch in terms of
important stuff definitely
but we haven't seen that yet so there
are these question marks
so if i'm sony i'm starting to try to
figure out exactly what i can do with
microsoft
uh they're clearly aggressive sharks
buying things
uh and whether or not i can get some
version of game pass on the service
because if i got a box that has game
pass and my first party stuff well
then i once again win the value i don't
know
i finally got hold of it okay yeah yeah
yeah and we gotta
yeah cause i was just about to respect
college because yeah
i just wanted to say real quick i think
the only thing that can sneak up on
microsoft in this regard is what hog's
saying which and this is actually
something that stuck up with sony during
the ps3 era and actually with netflix
which so they're different but with ps3
the more ps3s they sold
the worse they were doing financially
because they were losing money on
everyone sold
and the same thing with netflix i think
was happening netflix has only been
profitable i think
maybe the last couple of years and
disney plus apparently hundreds of
millions of dollars
with their own content so can you
imagine how many
billions and billions of dollars so
microsoft is going to lose on game pass
that's why when everyone anyone's ever
asked about it they're always like well
we're not trying to make
it's not a profit play or whatever the
hell they're hiring greenberg says it's
because you'll never admit how much
money you're losing on this because it's
not
good but it's it's kind of putting more
and more money into the center hoping
that everyone else loses first
because then everyone's going to come on
board and so i think hog's exactly right
like microsoft
if micro if sony was in microsoft's
place they'd be playing with serious
fire but microsoft has so much
money yeah yeah colleen before you go i
don't know you got to go
one last question that we normally do
for our guests is tradition and iop to
see you through
which is i never got your top five video
games or franchises
of all time i never got that interest oh
okay so
dude this answer would probably change
somewhat depending on the day you asked
me but right
mega man 3 is my favorite game of all
time um final fantasy 6
would be on that list castlevania
took a sword but that's my bad that's my
big game
would be on my list and then i guess
that last i would say like maybe
something like super mario world
um would be you know or super mario 3
something like that would be on that
list so
but that's the older i get the heart or
the harder that gets the answer right
you know and then your best console is
the nes right and yes
always forever i always have it very
special an absolute pleasure
to have you been around for a limited
time salute to you
this the story the journey again lily mo
games everything you're doing at last
time
our good friends over there you got the
fighting duke the whole movement
yeah dom again thank you for coming on
telling your story you're welcome in the
room anytime
tell the fine people to run where they
could find you what else you got going
on sir yeah hustle put all his links in
the chat
oh yeah please uh thank you uh yeah come
to just google last stand media if you
want to find the podcast sacred symbols
for playstation defining duke which is
done by
acg and mr maddie plays for xbox um
that's all under our umbrella i also do
a podcast with my brother in knockback
which is a retro podcast
um and then uh i make games or i write
them um so
i own part of a studio lillimo and uh we
just put out hybroxia too on everything
including on vita and uh
there's a bunch of ways to come find me
but i appreciate you guys i hope to come
back soon you guys are awesome
this is so different than my show it's
so nice to do
around like you know we do a much more
like a pbs style show
i do more of like a like an evening
commute kind of show and i love this
you know like i love this so now colin
you had a great guest on sacred symbols
plus
yeah oh yeah who is that oh yeah mr
hogue the only
guest i've ever had back three times
whoa that's right
sacred symbols plus which is our patreon
exclusive and we talk all about
uh legal you know legal stuff of course
as we would
so
yeah hit that up and go look at that
have a good one brother absolutely let's
continue
the discussion yes let's get back to the
mlb the show yes yes we gotta we gotta
get we gotta continue
i didn't remember if you got to finish
your points off because i don't know we
would rush it a bit
oh but no the mlb stuff listen man like
i i was already going to
purchase it on the xbox right the fact
that this game was going to multiple
platforms
i think it you know it is i think in my
opinion the best sports simulation
period
and and that's saying a lot when you
look at 2k basketball um i think it is
the best sport simulation out there and
to have it
everywhere is amazing right um
this was a power move by xbox to to do
this
and uh i would have never in a million
years seen this coming
yeah um so it's gonna be interesting
that first week
how the numbers pan out i really do want
to see this and like king was saying
like
at the end of the day i think mlb
obviously the money matters to them but
i think
the fact baseball is no longer the
national pastime as much as i love
baseball above all
other sports it's just not and to get it
into the hands of more people
to maybe find more fans is amazing to me
so yeah let's do it
king you didn't get a chance to finish
your obliviation sir
sure so
when it was coming over i was like yes
okay of course you know i have my
baseball cap ready
i'm ready playing for the the iop
challenges
like i'm taking on all challenges
so i i could not wait for this game to
show up
just to rub it in your sony dude's face
that's
just just to let you know your girl
ain't loyal
and i'm taking out we gonna get
something to eat
i had a whole tree thing set up and then
the unmistakable happened
dm me and said netflix and chill i said
well of course
chris
maximus aurelius spencer has put the
boot on your neck
i told you he is a shock he is an
absolute shock
and you guys thought it was a joke you
thought it was a joke this is what
happens when microsoft looks down and
say
oh you need money to do what what what
are you doing let me see your project
that's oh that's wonderful so you think
that you yeah and this is what we earned
and this is what's happening and this is
how many people
oh here here's the bank go do what you
got to do
and i see i don't think they're closing
down any studios in the next four or
five years at all
the only reason why is because they they
brought uh people that are able to
produce their own games and work under
their own situation
i think those games will ever be on the
sony's platform
because only the games that's under
contract
hold already knows games is under
contract it's not the viability in
breaking a contract they can go through
a long long
drawn-out legal battle or whatever which
will make no sense to throw money into
that for no reason
just put it over there put it over here
in game pass for free and this is the
last time you're going to eat at this
table
right because exclusivity which is
sony's game
microsoft has heard it enough is where
people want to go
right so i don't want to do no patchwork
game pass on playstation either you take
the full game pass
or you don't take nothing at all they're
going to beat them
to death this is this is the last time i
told you this is the last playstation
card oh lord
and the reason why i say this right
because like like
like um the great collins said
in a war of attrition
in a war of attrition sony cannot
compete and
you know that felt so good understanding
that they also see the long game
in the long game that dude who you know
who is more fortified in this situation
can actually
withstand this battle right so we know
the last time sony had stiff competition
which was the 360 well hey
we know what happened there and you know
leadership got out of that early and
went on to the xbox one x and
bad leadership can mess stuff up to the
don you got bad leadership now
at sony right and i don't know
if they can get a proper person in place
that can turn it around in its manner
right they can't change
the ps now platform and the ps plus
platform in such a quick manner
to make it viable for them in my opinion
right
at it to be honest with you king like i
know like you know
uh lord hogan uh you know calling they
they want
xbox to bring game pass i don't think
sony is saying no because of because of
game pass
and it's micros i think they're saying
no because they they see what
microsoft's doing across the way they're
like okay
like look right now we good but we're
gonna build up this now
as much as we can that way if stuff goes
south we drop in day and day
like and i feel like if they invite gay
pass onto their platform
they're going to hurt themselves more
they're going to help themselves because
i truly believe
that we're going to get to a point where
consoles aren't a thing anymore and it's
just going to be these things
yeah these playstation hours these game
pass and i think
sony knows that but they know it's not
right now or anytime soon
and they know that if they build up this
platform and stuff gets really bad
they could just drop stuff on that day
and date and they'll be fine and i think
that's the reason they won't let game
pass on their server
because then they're going to be
competing with each other yeah exactly
look you know it's it's an interesting
thing obviously this thing
was was catastrophic news for for a lot
of people you know for different
different sides of the fence but um yeah
i just want to i want to pivot just a
little bit because i know what time
we've been going along
and i want to kind of combine a little
bit with the services being that we kind
of transition
so the whole thing now you know we have
obviously this big news with game pass
obviously the question then becomes okay
from
a service standpoint you know what does
if someone even chooses to compete in
that space and then the other thing that
we i want to kind of combine
in a jumbo topic is um game preservation
and now
i know we talked pecan earlier about a
little bit of that you know with david
and stuff
you know so one what do you think about
you know their sony's approach would
gain preservation obviously we know
about the digital storefronts closing
and then the second part would be about
what do you think about as far as their
on a service standpoint you know what do
they do to maybe do anything to bolster
ps now
or any you know in comparison to game
pass so let's get on let's get on dead
nick nicholas first and then we get um
we get hope well
here's my biggest problem with sony
because i lo i love my playstation 5. i
love the games on my playstation 5. i
love my playstation 4. i love the games
on my playstation 4.
but here's the problem i also love the
games on my playstation 3.
and i also loved all the playstation 1
classics that were on my playstation
vita
and one of the best aspects of
playstation
is its history yeah you know you tell
you talk to a lot of people
whether you know they start gaming on
nintendo playstation or wherever there's
very few people you talk to in the
gaming space
that don't have a loving memory of
something on a playstation console
whether it's metal gear
or kill zone or whatever the case may be
um
i just think it's incredibly important
to keep those games
alive in some form i don't have an
answer for how to keep those games alive
like
could we get to a point where it's like
the movies where like i believe there's
like a government-based archive
of films and everything else could we
get to that point with video games
maybe down the road maybe that's
something we could look into i don't
know
because that's not exactly my field i'm
just spitballing here
um but i just i can't vibe with
the energy that i saw online where
everyone's like well i only care about
new games
i don't care about games on the
playstation vita i can't
get behind that idea because your new
games will eventually become
old games and then they don't all of a
sudden stop mattering like
it's 2021 and i still write articles
about doom 1993
and i can play you can play doom you can
play
you you can write you can literally play
doom 1993 someone got that working on a
pregnancy test
do 1993 is playable anywhere and i love
that because when i talk about new 1993
or
i write about one person will come to me
and go hey i bought this on steam i
bought this on playstation i bought this
on xbox wherever they bought it
instead i got to experience a piece of
gaming history
right and when you when you when you
don't have game preservation you
lose that history right and like the oh
my only criticism of the whole thing
i want xbox to keep adding more games i
know they say they will i want them keep
building on that history and pulling it
forward because it's a great
point because we've seen so many
articles the past few weeks
and videos and everything else and
people going i really love my
playstation 5
but i really like how fluid backwards
compatibility is
on the series x because you don't you're
not
losing things right and that's the
that's the biggest takeaway
and like yeah i don't think there's a
high population of people
on playstation 3. it's from a money
standpoint closing the playstation 3
store and closing the video store
business sense wise it makes sense
gotcha
part two part two because i don't want
to lose out of the part two part which
is
the ps now you know uh
possibly doing anything in reference to
in in a competitor or do you think they
just
don't look to to care to bolster that
that's not their focus their focus is on
the new
games and not necessarily trying to
bolster that service to put in any type
of competition we get past
if you had asked me in 2019 if they
would reconfigure
playstation now to be more viable
against game pass i'd probably
undoubtedly say yes under their previous
leadership i 100
percent believed they would be
reevaluating ps now and looking at a way
to
better compete with xbox on it but jim
ryan has
quite publicly outspoken that they don't
need this a service like that
and that you know their games aren't
sustainable in a model like that
so anyone that's thinking that you know
all of a sudden they're going to go date
or anything like that
it's just not going to happen because
the leadership itself does not believe
that's sustainable i think he flip-flops
a lot so because he also believed in
generations but that's not true so
maybe tomorrow maybe tomorrow tomorrow
for you tomorrow maybe tomorrow the
thing that when it comes to
the you know the generations i i get
what people say that these aren't games
that you know i care about these are old
games like
uh like five ten years from now when you
can't have access to god of war the
original one like are we going to have
that same energy
like the the infamous you know uh one
and two i i don't think that came or
we're gonna have the same energy like
didn't he say he didn't like how gran
turismo look
yeah he wants to play that who wants to
play
[Laughter]
the thought process behind a lot of this
stuff is really messed up
but i told you guys when y'all were
getting them he's a numbers dude
he's going to run the number he's going
to crunch the numbers he's going to see
what's viable what's not viable he's
going to trim the fat
you know they brought in a numbers dude
because their margin of error is so
slim that they can't afford to have
these uh hiccups those hiccups cannot be
happening
so if they're bleeding money in one area
just to do a fan service
he's gonna trim the fat in that area now
do they bring that stuff back around in
playstation now in some form of capacity
that uh you can purchase these games
over inside the store
i can see that happening i can see him
doing a business move of that nature
but if something is bleeding in money
and you bring in a numbers guy
to work the numbers don't be upset when
he's doing numbers things
this is his job right and
he he had two of the most successful
launches in playstation history
two right so he's done with the
playstation 4. he's down with the
playstation 5.
most successful launches you can you can
cry and moan
if he's doing one thing on this side in
a numbers way
and then cry if he's trimming the fat
here right
i keep getting this tweet over and over
again people want me to say this tweet
right on here uh shout out to chess
gordon
he says don't believe this idol being
pushed by some that
xbox game pass isn't making money it
isn't sustainable i know for a fact that
it's simply untrue
i did what i was asked to do people
people want to correct stuff that you
know
not everything is appeared how is it is
there you go
randolph or no doubt let's get let's get
home again man because
we got to move we got to get these two
topics in so yeah yeah but well i mean i
think yeah i'm sorry
in all honesty i think the the topic has
been well covered i for me preservation
the biggest issue that you have is that
it is primarily
more of an emotional appeal than a
financial appeal we've talked about
businesses and fiduciary duty and i
think if you want to
spin exactly why they should be
preserving why they should be taking
steps like xbox and microsoft are doing
which by the way
it should not be ignored that they used
that to help populate their service when
they were going through a kind of fallow
period
of first-party gains right and so it was
still a business decision on their part
to say oh look we can use our history we
can do this backward compatibility and i
love it i think everybody that looks at
the the two boxes and says
sometimes the xbox just feels more
folsom because you can pull up a game
from
15 years ago even if you're not
necessarily going to do it
it just feels good and i think you
that's the pitch to the sony's of the
world is saying well look
um out of the three companies apologies
to the xbox fans uh sitting on the
podcast here
i i would have preferred any of the
other companies to be the
preservationist over microsoft just
because
i don't love microsoft's history as much
as i love nintendo's or sony's right
you'll love it
you love it later because you got we got
to wear outriders
are you saying he's going to go back to
like the high school sweetheart no no no
no
no no what he's saying is his nostalgia
is is based here his nostalgia and his
stuff is based in this area
you have a fond memory of playstation
games and nintendo games and
their preservation of those games is
definitely something for you
but like my son right now who's growing
up on xbox 360
and it's growing up on xbox one and he's
moving on to xbox series s
his preservation starts at xbox so he
would look at you and say i don't care
about nintendo i asked him if he wanted
to play station five he looked at me
like i had two heads what are you like
it's like it's it's individualized
absolutely but this is absolutely your
part but i
feel you me too i'm wearing all three
too don't get me wrong
i think preservation is important i 100
love what xbox has done
i loved popping back into pray and
seeing it boosted and all that good
stuff
i think it's a great box and i think
they're doing a great job and i agree
with everybody here who
has said that they have gotten a more
progressive
advanced aggressive uh business model
and stance and really direction and
drive
over sony right now um but sony is
effectively and we knew this before the
generation started going forward with
the old ways right that they're going to
have a wall garden they're going to make
some
aaa products that's going to sell them
and and we don't care about backwards
compatibility
we ditched playstation 2 compatibility
in the playstation 3 really as soon as
we could
and we don't think it's necessarily
going to make us money
uh so i do think that there's a pitch to
be made
that as microsoft grows and and as game
pass
makes money which i think it will do
hopefully it will do
uh that you can look at sony and say
guys you've got
if not stronger history we don't want to
give them that you've got as much
history as microsoft
and xbox and you should be thinking
about how to do that and that's good
will and i think
from a financial perspective i look at
it as something akin to
short term versus long term preach
you're probably not going to have a
bunch of people
playing that old version of siphon
filter that you've gotten working on
your playstation 5 except maybe hope
but you are going to generate that we
care about our brand we care about what
you have invested in both financially
and emotionally
and we want you to continue to invest in
that in the future and that's what phil
spencer
and xbox has done is he's attached to
gamers look this is important to you
you've spent hours of your short time on
earth
playing our products and we want to be
able to bring those memories to you and
sony said hey
the future only and you know i
understand that
but i think that you do get into
situations where your news item if
you're sony is
you're closing old stores when are you
going to close network access
is my playstation 3 even going to work
can i play these games that i bought
before and if you start getting those
little cracks
in the edifice then yeah it's easier to
say
phil spencer wants me to play all my
games and so
he also gave me outriders right and i
say this
um if you have a series x is a great
machine to play all those playstation
games
you know if you lost them they're there
the ios podcast is not condoned
what i say is these
look for those solutions for your
problems
i did a video in the xbox actually you
should check it out in virtually god
like it's getting to the point king i
think i think we need a king's world
we need the same gift but king's face on
there not mine
i feel like can't be having more kings
world moment
yeah but bootlegging with the kings
hey i didn't say that all i said is we
have solutions for you
we have some nurses
or the window of opportunity is closing
and sun setting on you
don't allow it to sense i don't like
this voice
is anything ps now you feel should do
your thoughts
i think that sony look
i get where he's coming from like the
piracy thing
but like to me i i can't front him a
whole lot on that because it's just like
if sony doesn't respect their own legacy
why should you
know wow it might like be a morally gray
area but let's be real like if sony
doesn't respect their own stuff to make
sure it comes with you
why should you respect them legally
and i'm not saying go out there and
pirate this stuff but it's just like
yes are you implying are you implying
when these are shut down and you can no
longer buy them
at that point how else are you going to
get them yeah
i mean well that that opens up the
market right and yeah i mean yeah it's
it it's it's an interesting proposition
let me let me ask you the ps4 because
i'm very curious like
you know with everything that game pass
is doing you know do you think they even
need to respond or do you think they
even care about that speech
i'm just saying they need a response
since they bought bethesda like
like like they keep people oh they don't
need to do nothing they don't do that
look it's fire over here what's going
down
sony they've been smoked for months
oh you implied it's a cold red addict
are we afraid there are
people sitting there like oh it's okay
and they they're like
you you they're like looking out in the
window and like the whole house is on
fire
and they're like we're we're fine we
good over here no you ain't sold
i said that from the beginning but i
also said with this new leadership there
is growing pains he wants to implement
how things are going to get done
he wants to change things around you
can't be happy
when he lowers the price down to
playstation now or he does things like
this
to to bolster up numbers and subscribers
and you know he's he's
giving you these exclusive titles that
y'all talked about
you know um but you can't be upset
when he has to do these things right he
has to show his his
um his he has to show his value to the
company
right well he knows i mean he's
dominated europe he's you know
he he's he's changed that he's changed
position let me just
he's positioned himself to jump in and
um
you know basically when we talked about
the um
the changing of the guard with the
japanese studios and and then kind of
dispersing roles and stuff like that
things are so big
correctly but um the thing that we've
noticed even from the early outset of
the playstation 5 and i've said this on
a couple other podcasts is that
one thing traditionally as we and you
know king like when we used to get the
japanese playstation
you know cross would always be the
confirmation in the us and circle
would be confirmation on japanese side
and something that i thought was very a
lot of people
talk about is that was changed on the
playstation 5. and it got a lot of
cultural traditional uproar
because it also to me represented the
shift
as far as priority let me let me i just
want to add this one part
that i it just it was like a little bit
right now
um i've noticed that
from that comment that he said with the
gran turismo right
this was an inevitability it could be
right like and you're talking about that
uh
history right he doesn't really care
about the history
right with the buttons like those but
that meant a lot right that was just
yeah cultural significance there's an
emotional significance and also again
you know like you said kind of from a
number standpoint
he may be put in position or i have have
helped ascend
because of the dominance of playstation
in europe
right yes and we know what that did for
the generation so i guess the question
becomes with the numbers
if he's able to to justify his worth
with the numbers
and and and others now that the regime
has changed was it later than a couple
other guys
you know maybe that was that philosophy
change that helped him ascent i want to
get started because i want to go over
his points too so
quickly solve um your feelings on the
playstation now
should they do anything should they
change and then obviously the game
presence we can't do that because we get
to that point
i know i don't know we're going to lose
combine the topics that close us out so
i don't know i it just feels like hubris
to me man
it really does feel like yes not that
not that far-fetched
but the fact that you know jim ryan
still stays on this stance about
not you know it not being that important
to them and seeing what microsoft is
doing
there's very few times i will tell you
that they need to directly respond to
xbox in the same
in the same manner that xbox is doing to
them right
what i mean by that is doing the exact
same thing in this
instance like hogue said when you have
when when when you have the back
compatibility bolstering up your sort of
lineup while games are actually coming
new games are actually ready to come out
you get people to start seeing the value
of your service and little by little
when you start making the one-to-one
comparison you're like why wouldn't i be
over here right and and then not for
whatever reason they feel it seems like
they feel like they're still impervious
to that comparison and they're not
so then when they make these moves right
and and last
last week when we spoke about it it was
speculation we didn't know yet now we
know exactly what they're going to do
there was nothing in that statement that
indicated hey look out for what we're
going to do with this
look out for how we're going right there
was no additional incentive right
we have a plan for you exactly that
these stores are closing and none of
that
last point because you're making a good
point is the the short term notice which
which even colin had mentioned on his
show which is
you know as a developer for veto
whatever like right it wasn't even like
it was like a couple of months so it's
like this developed case and stuff that
was going to be made but continue
precisely so he's like you know he's
like wait they just basically told us i
can't make my last game on peter i can't
do it
um and and the thing about it is to to
continue to treat that like it's this
side thing and it doesn't matter
when you have somebody who's grown up
with playstation like us right and we
we have reverence for old playstation
and
you know and to say that like like attic
mentions like well
at some point god of war 2018 is an old
game at some point
right what do you do then so are you
saying
are you saying that the playstation 4 is
the jumping of the playstation 5 should
i say
is the jumping off point where backwards
compatibility is going to matter moving
forward
are you saying that are you not saying
that you're they're probably not saying
that they're probably saying
hey we're going to give you this ps4
back compat because hey we sold almost
150 million of these
i don't want to i don't want to lose
that base yet but when it comes to ps6
will you have would you be able to play
ps4 games on it i don't know i don't
think so
exactly there ain't no ps6 no it's just
not after what phil doing
i really don't care if it financially it
it's it makes sense for them to do it
like hogue mentioned i think it's a
matter of creating value for your
for your fan base that's going to
continue to support you throughout all
of these generations and all these
councils
to create a legacy for them that they
can go back to
it just doesn't make any sense it's like
they and when i talk about the hubris
it's like
we just care about your money right now
we don't care what you spent in the past
that's in the past we don't care we
don't care about your feelings
in a very nice as nice way as they can
possibly say they're saying that
and it just doesn't make any sense when
you continue to see xbox
just giving more value to the thing
they're offering you so
you know you cannot you can no longer
say that comparison is is
isn't one to one because at some point
somebody's going to look at both these
consoles
and decide which one they're going to go
with right and
you know it's just xbox keeps making the
compelling argument in terms of the ps
now thing
we've talked about this forever how do
they what's a way that they can maintain
this legacy right right put these games
in the cloud and allow you to access
them in the cloud right
the fact of the matter is we we heard
about this azure thing with them for for
the longest time we've heard nothing
about them moving
servers over to azure right there's been
no talk
of of improving ps now right
at all at all there's been no talk about
hey ps now moving forward is going to be
this yeah they have a bunch of games in
there
and yeah the fact that you can download
ps4 games is cool and i've heard people
say oh you can download ps2 games no no
you can't download ps2 games
you can download ps2 games that were
that that
that were made available on the ps4 that
they were
all right right yeah right now
exactly they were remade for the ps4 so
that you could play them there
so obviously it proves that it can be
done he believes in generations
movement in inter in in ps now because
ps now
as it stands now right cannot handle
pushing all of these games onto there
and that's how their legacy is gonna
without with it
the way the way guy kai works
is just not nearly as efficient as right
yeah there's no
way in hell so we would have to really
see them talk about hey
at some point azure is going to be the
backbone of this
and this is how we plan to grow this and
if they talk about that then yeah then
maybe they can do that but they're not
talking about it so
my belief like colin said jim ryan's on
the clock
and i think and i think what he does
with this
i think reading these tea leaves is
gonna it's gonna determine
where he is i think he's highly
successful i think he's in a cat bird
seat
is it all you need to be made for that
it's an argument to be here would this
emma be the show thing
this mlb the show thing just does it bad
but so me me and cog were talking
and i was like uh you know i was like
you know would be funny
and i know king's probably not gonna
like this statement but i was like
f at the end of this generation gym
dance move ryan's made sony more money
off the playstation brand than any
generation
or past leader before and then it
becomes funny it's going to be hard to
change the course but look let's let's
rap i gotta we got a ton of super chats
yeah we got like absurd and we gotta
figure out what we're gonna do about
that and then also out of the rest we
got
the extra guests because i can't have
them sit through that uh
lord hogue and lord undead all again i
want to thank you guys for coming in
around
pulling up last minute and giving first
of all the lord of virtually god it's
always a blessing to have you in the
realm man
colin was a dual treat nice nice cameo
appearance you know yeah
thank you for inviting me absolutely
absolutely where can the five people
find you what you got going on sir
absolutely well uh people can find me on
twitter at hoglaw where i'm regularly
talking about my michigan wolverines and
video games and lawn things along those
lines
but most prominently i have the youtube
channel called virtual legality where we
talk about
the business and law of video games
music movies television and pop culture
and we do it
on a fairly regular basis although my
viewers are
pretty upset for me taking a week off
yeah yeah i was i was
going to happen to to to be covering the
gaming and stream so much
crazy [ __ ] always be happening in the
game i tell you what you know when i
started this in 2018 one of my thoughts
was
you know i'm not sure there's gonna be
enough content
that was quickly uh that was quickly
assuaged as i basically can't keep up i
basically
have a list i have a word document where
i have great
fans a great community who sends me all
these ideas
and then i have to pick one while also
running a law firm
so it's uh matter of picking and
choosing but it's a great
it's a great thing and hopefully uh my
channel is helping to
get a little bit more and better
information about the specifics of
things like the bethesda deal when
uh maybe some of the articles aren't as
specific as they maybe should be
the funny thing is like anytime
something happens like a me and cog
start like
debating on something i'm like dude
that's my new thing
yeah okay i ain't going with that we
gotta we gotta really break down
absolutely brother you are
reconnaissance i need that whole video
to drop so we can stop this
i love what you bring to the gaming
space and i love supporting it because
at the end of the day
it's all about clarity and learning how
these things work from a legal
standpoint from a contractual standpoint
acquisition all that good stuff
and then obviously i got to get the the
occasion of the whole slanted when he
when he feels a certain way about
certain
topics or possible little mass effect uh
yes
there's a twitter going around with what
what opinion gives you these swords to
your neck
hey lord cognito you don't think i have
any of these do you
no i think everybody does and i love
this industry i love video gaming
and uh i have my whole life so it's it's
fun to talk about on youtube and with
you all absolutely
you know what's funny we have when we
have that uh that debate show
yeah you know you're going to be my
cleanup hitter
like i'm not going to lie man originally
i was on call excited i was like oh
i got to say i think saul's team bought
them up
you could have all the superstars you
want but you all got that great team you
got to play
you got to play the game baby so listen
i know what i'm up against but i'm ready
now i'm ready
you know absolutely but like salute the
whole man again for coming through
and again having a fantastic uh
perspectives on things
this is a happy sad moment for me with
what
alumni now we gotta call you an alumni
and now with
android central the legend himself
pulling up
nicholas downey aka undead 3 xvi where
can the five people find what you got
going on sir
well if people want to find me they can
find me on twitter at undead 3 xvi i
would not recommend it because
it's basically swords at your neck
opinions
and of course you can find all my
written work at android central and
windows central and i've got a bioware
related piece on what they need to do
with uh
mass effect oh you're like fixed for all
the problems with mass effect 1 that
are you doing that to make it actually
playable you should focus on that
being that they're fixing things
bang bang bang
i'm sorry i'm sorry i did i interrupted
you you're great great no no it's fine
because you know what
the best part is i haven't played a mass
effect game so awesome remasters come
out i'm going to come in and i'm
immediately going to have a team
um i'll be playing through the game
going this is where i'm going to be at
make sure you play the originals first
and then so you get proper contacts
you
now before again respectfully guess you
guys can definitely head out because we
have to pay the bills and i don't want
you guys to sit for maybe 30 minutes if
we have to do that
absolutely well thanks again for having
me yes thank you brother
much appreciated you guys you guys are
awesome all right man all right
solve addict how you want to handle do
you want to do it i'm on it
are you on it okay all right so before
you're on it
i did i got to do the uh the i didn't
even do the poll question
which was um yeah so no i propose with
the recent announcement of mlb the show
coming to game pass day and date how do
you think
sony should respond hey choices are
sony should be more aggressive with
timed exclusive game deals and beef up
playstation plus quality b
sony should stand pat and focus on high
quality
aaa first party studios see
sony should retool and completely
reinvigorate ps now
or d i don't care game pass is
unsustainable bad for developers
and real gamers need to buy their games
now super chats and then i'll just get
about it yeah
we got a lot of schedules we didn't
disrespect you guys we got you
yeah we got you we only had
oh we have a lot of super chats so thank
you guys you really really i came
through okay
um we got flame five dollars we chat for
phil have shown his light upon
good friday and said unto people who
wants to play baseball
my treat go back to my
treat
take your fans out to the ball
then we have malik tyler once again with
the one dollar super chat thanks once
again for the support
and we got the everborn saga two dollar
super chat
for the watch
he was oh he was on board
then we got drunk and ninja five dollars
super chat colin just described how i
feel with outriders salute lords and
good to see y'all
that's right then we got our brother
boom double barrel gaming five dollar
super chat shout out to my brothers
this is awesome colin i'm a huge fan we
and why boys need to collab in the
future factual
factual then we got eric j
the homie five dollars jackson shout out
to my ielts big brothers blessings
uh blessing us with this special edition
tuesday show in the realm with the one
and only lord colin martin legendary
what a show fantastic show then we got
gerald mack 10
super chat shout out to the lords good
afternoon i have to admit it's crazy
seeing you on a tuesday afternoon but
just like
yesterday where the lords go i follow oh
wow
thank you thank you so much and thank
you for that teespring it's already
honest with you
thanks um then we have edcasting at
christie with the five dollar super chat
question for everyone here knowing that
the main character of near replicant has
sold himself into prostitution
how does this make you feel yeah i have
no idea what he's talking about
yeah so there have been some changes to
to near
and this remake of the first one um yeah
listen man the streets are tough man you
do what you got to do
we read this one already lord jameson
hundred dollars jet thank you so much my
brother i appreciate that
so much then we have kendrick starr five
dollars a chat
i had a saturn with the switch and four
and one card saturn was good thank you
very much
there we go then we got rubber knob over
here
like i said the rubber knob i
the prequel and the sequel trump yes it
did yes this is true
and we have mass erect
good evening lords i'm ready for the
smoke yes sir
king king got his bars on that's for
sure
then we got raiden blade with the two
pound super chat hello gents almost
missed the show outrider's fault
thank you then we got family one away
dragons tv
chat what's good fam chat let's get lit
happy tuesday no doubt my brother
we got one of the dragons again two
dollar super chat socom is a classic
like reeboks
5411 sony no doubt no doubt
then we got gamers play with the 5 super
chat x-band had fighting games mortal
kombat and eternal champions
my friends used to call it eternal
wackness that's oh damn yeah
i like it from the champions league then
we got jb golden two dollars
totally um about totally on about the
quality
ripped to the cow magura okay
then we got oh lord jameson again with
the six with the final super chat over
600 watching hit that like button
then we got fonzarelli gaming ah five
dollars
no doubt my brother just want to say
awesome show lords
also i was a huge fan of podcast beyond
the chemistry and info was great
was one of my go-to podcasts
now then we have one away dragon's tv 10
super chat
colin moriarty is my favorite interview
yet he's dropped a real info on
journalism
and the banter that's being created
being and being willing to separate from
the toxic perception
great job lords facts
yeah for sure i saw people in the chat
who'd never heard of colin yeah
or or had a certain perception of him
and it came out of the chat different
yeah and that that was especially during
your moment so we'll get to you
then we got drunken ninja three dollar
super chat we need a don demarco for
sob's amazing insight
that you're up to marco and he was like
preaching preaching no doubt no doubt we
got
mass arrest he back
xbox gamers doing the ditty bop yeah
then we got z black writer with the ten
dollar super chat
most of the world can converse america
is the hammer don't talk politics you
know nothing about
okay okay okay then we got lord i don't
i didn't know if that was adams
anyways expect the context then we got
uh lord jameson again two dollars in the
chat no time for colin's top five we got
to it brother we got
it we got you bro we saved the stairs i
couldn't let them leave the room without
that
then we got dan lazzaro with the 5 super
chat xbox is attacking playstation with
the death by a thousand cuts method
playstation is looking down at their
body and thinking oh god
when did that cut happen
savages then we got corey hale with the
15
super chat that will be the show game
pass i called it
profit corey hair no doubt then we have
the rubber knob
with the five dollars what if sony put
it on there as a test to see what
numbers it brings in to see if it would
be viable to do the same on their
platform
no i'll answer that for you they didn't
i think i think if if the numbers come
back really crazy
you got and purchase wise and stuff like
that you might see something strange
going on game pass
remember you got a numbers dude on the
other end this this is the
this is the epitome of everyone else
around that is that baby jim ryan
i just having the being caught with
their pants down i just want you to know
that i have doordash coming and if this
isn't over by the time it gets here
i will be eating my burgers
this ain't the first time this ain't the
first time you went and got food like
like you act like it's something
after three hours i'm eating okay
so attic do me a favor um grab
from i thought you were asking for food
i was about to pick no no no no
yo the way he said yo addict the door
dash make sure i get that
all right from cat daddy from cat daddy
grab those because i'm reading and i'm
not able to copy these so from cat daddy
just copy those
get from cat daddy down oh no just cat
daddy uh just felt like adding to the
workload no no yeah exactly from there
i i i have the actual thing up so when
we get to it i'll read the rest
okay um hold on one second let me go
back to this
um then we have vagabond with the five
dollars with the chat
they're all making it way complicated
it's unlikely mlb employees who play
video games
all have one console or the other okay
okay
you got raiden blade five pound super
chat uncle phil is like mmm
time to release my inner each girl
be compliant bunk guy hold my game fast
oh my god wow
this is a chess move yes it is we got
raiden blade five pound super chat now
i'm with king david this might be the
last playstation 5.
it caused playstation to make a lot to
the to make a lot to develop
it's best to put their software on xbox
wow
yeah they got the studio just give us
your games
this is a sticker i'm playing already
stop playing already
just give us the games then we got ready
to play it again two dollars with the
chat oh it's two pounds super chat
spiderman game pass lol
savages yeah and we have a
mass erect yes again again two dollars
he was out there and we got the iop who
did that for you my man phil
is the one who did that for you rate him
play once again two pound super chat the
world's most dangerous and nice man phil
spencer yeah phil spencer has this
silent assassin thing going right now
like he really does i told y'all from
the jump
i told you
i didn't know if he had that killer what
you i thought he was super nice and
it wasn't sure but now he in position he
he's proven when he's in position
yeah yeah he got what he got the gap you
gotta yeah you gotta run
act like we've been here longer than we
feel like we haven't seen
it yeah it's only we have the three hour
marks oh okay
it's just it's the afternoon now yeah
it's because exactly i'm not used to it
it's dark i was like then we got gilbert
kitchens kitchens five dollars super
chat
sony would directly see the number of
players jumping into their game via game
pass
could this be a move to push sony to
finally compete
compete by putting this stuff on gamepad
give us your game
keep watching give us your games we'll
give you guys stop the beatings hand the
games over
then we got six slam five super chat
this is the most ridiculous
l ever it's like sideshow bob walking
into that field full of rakes
continually slapping him in the face oh
my god this is crazy not a good look
and we got mass erect yes again
two dollar super chat spider-man is next
and
here it comes yo
when it happens you'll be like oh snap
[Laughter]
snap
we got easy shock with the five dollar
super chat this might be the best panel
lineup from iop
ever thank you so much
and we got king one supreme five dollar
super chat here to see king put on a
jordan flu game performance
first mlb nexus quantic dream detroit
become human beyond two souls on game
pass
book of x thank you brother i definitely
had my flu moment
i had to move through the crowd you know
as scotty as i was leaning on scotty i
was looking at scotty
i had to drop that double nickel on them
late late to the show but shamar with
the spoon let's welcome the newest
member of the realm absolutely put those
crests in the chat
what's up that's what's thank you
brother much much much thanks and we
have a
gaming times patrick with the five
dollar super chat just wanted to drop
some love for the podcast and the
esteemed guests
yes thank you and we got felix with the
five dollar super chat netflix
disney hbo max nintendo and sony don't
own the pipes
don't own the servers big direct
difference with microsoft
yep that is true yeah we lend them out
sony down with us
they invest in games over
then we have rrd with the two dollar
super chat shout out to iop
my favorite podcast xbox winning
hashtag winning and we have
mass erect once again oh my god
five dollar super chat thank you brother
sony needs to save all their pennies in
order to compute xbox now
this is true man that's not fair that's
not false it really is that's that's sad
how true that is
out here kendrick starr five dollars if
you chat somebody always starts slow at
launch
it's just more noticeable now because
xbox is killing it like they did in the
360 days
that is true that is true yeah this is
the fight they ain't gonna give up
yo you know what i think this is
honestly and i know he's gonna yell out
time
but you ever seen an old champ like he
get in the ring he just old that night
yeah this i think he got old overnight
that's the yeah that's the night that
they age like yeah i think we should
he'll think he's sharing this slip i see
it
you stupid we got michael aka best docs
finest two dollar super chat sony is
dead
god bless david and keep my car
he
[Laughter]
your chat blockbuster didn't need to do
nothing too okay
and there they go they were winning
before remember that
yeah then once again mass erects with
the two dollar super chats
sony's pocket's full of lent like the
joker lent in his pockets
then we got michael aka best side's
finest two dollars chat rumor that
battlefield 6
is also coming to game pass yeah that's
a high possibility
then we have the rubber knob with the
ten dollar super chat
sony fans last week were screaming out
not to join game pass it was bad for the
industry yeah i saw that that was
crazy now they're screaming we want a
playstation pass oh how the post moves
the game has changed come
join us please
then we got the rubber knob once again
with the five dollars in the chat xbox
be standing on sony's chest having to
scream off
and we have andy crawley with the five
dollar super chat
hi lords keep rocking in the free world
thanks for keeping it real you know
as far as i got i got more um oh i'm
sorry you got oh you caught up too good
got it yeah i have it so we got two
dollar super chat from cat daddy
just felt like adding to the workload
right now
absolutely a 2 2 super chat from mass
erect
xbox to buy my bomb is on your lips
xboxes what is going on
well we got a five dollar super trap
from the wise old gamer
so uh phil to sony your goal belongs to
the streets
he put up the crest so he got a picture
of it i thought that picture was
beautiful
you got a five dollar super chat from a
damn mess
that is a damn mess
for some reason since he had the a
capitalized
from the streets that she emerged and to
the streets she shall return
i am phil i came i saw i
dropped the bag and took from you who
did that for you
you gotta give that the biblical he was
in his bag when he created that
ashes dustin yeah like he got real
biblical with that super chat
yeah all right you got a bigger you got
a two dollar super chat from victor
great show support thank you brother
thank you thank you we got a five dollar
super chat from hustle and motivate
y'all keep up the great work you
all are truly uh inspirational
onward and upwards thank you brother you
gotta fight all this super trap from
black ronin
you didn't say nothing man next time say
something
you gotta fight out super chat from
gaming forte words can't express how
proud you guy uh you got made me this
was a momentum
achievement and this is the only the
beginning shout out to my second family
the iop
thank you brother hold on a second
let me read this from jb golden because
the the the khao maguru thing
yeah he said lord saab that super chat
was way back during the game facts talk
yes i know
uh kyle mcgirl is one of the main super
writers of fighting game facts look at
that we probably use this guy's work so
many times
no yeah thank you no doubt mm-hmm
all right so we got to find out from
brat salute lords need to catch the
replay
dope thank you we got a we got a five
dollar super chat from
no no let hold on let's solve read that
from slo-mo
yes let's all read that one and why why
not you need to read that no you need to
be there
evening gentlemen addict great show as
usual just here to remind you that
people refuse to play
mass effect 1 until it's fixed mass
effect 2 didn't need to remaster yeah
the horse can control the narrative
super chat i know you're ready to eat
i'm just trying to keep
all right let's get our outros out lord
addict
tremendous show today proud of y'all my
brother proud of you
where can i find people friends what you
got going on sir follow me on twitter
at lord addict iop you can also find
my last show the attic show i did
yesterday on my
oh man we got a two dollar super chat
from gaming
hey king booboo hey
let me say this really fast you can find
me on twitter
lord is iop you can find me in king
doing our
second um show on um
it takes two tomorrow i don't know what
time it's gonna be probably around noon
is one-ish
yeah you can also find uh my last show
the attic show i did my impressions on
the playstation 5 with kid smooth
now let's hurry up and do these sections
before they troll us more let's go
here we go
i want to honestly thank you nothing i
can say nothing i can say can convey my
gratitude
i feel if it wasn't for your prayers i
wouldn't be here thank you wow
thank you brother i love you love you
brother it's good to see you
behind you 100 did we get hustle
motivate hold this w yes you gotta get
it continue go go go go go go go go go
go go go go go go go go
mass erect the two dollars in the chat
pause
yeah yeah frank lauren five dollars
shout out to the lords on the tuesday i
think my last super got snipes for song
lyrics oh really
oh great stuff as always really that's
crazy i know they can snipe your super
chat
so yeah lord song where can you find
people first of all
again proud of your brother about all of
you but uh definitely proud of you
saw you was in your bag got everybody
emotional you know what i'm saying but
you were spitting your bars you had to
get it off listen man
big shout out to you know where you can
find me i'm going back to work a couple
of days i'm gonna enjoy this
you know while i can't but uh big shout
out to colin man i hate i think
[Laughter]
you you guys know what we represent here
at iop you know that you don't put the
rest of the um
the the the games and supercharged yes
oh you know what we represent we're
gonna talk to anybody and everybody in
the industry
we don't we don't go with any of that
sort of cancer culture stuff
colin is a dude that i followed from the
very beginning of his sort of gaming
career
and the dude is is so intelligent and
he's always been very gracious and and
everything what happened that that was
not a good look for us as
as a gaming community and i hope if the
one thing that i hope that came out of
this is that people who came into this
thinking that they knew about colin came
out with a different
perspective yeah and if you didn't know
about him you came away saying
yo this dude is somebody i got to follow
yeah um so
you know i forgot to say something
because i'm trying to in the show before
you know morgan
attack us from super chats i definitely
want to you know thank you
colin for coming on like i i want to
just point into the kind of perspective
people call and sighs are almost
impossible to get all of yeah
and then if you get a hold of them nine
times out of ten they're giving you
some type of excuse and it's not
necessarily anything bad on their
character or anything like that
but we're just some random email
emailing them and
and you know colin was like i got you
send me an email and i've been talking
to him since february
and he came on the show that's a very
rare sight addict made it happen and
at the end of the day like i said you
know yeah respect for that for him
choosing our platform
to to trust uh you know trust that would
so definitely get that see what you had
in this song
dj birdo with the father loves you hold
you was on fire today got a couple of
bars off but you know
you you you ain't you're back you know
you're definitely proud of you
too you know from hearing this story
from solve uh
because i don't i don't go to other
people uh you know stuff i don't i don't
i'm really trust me i'm all in my head
trying to figure out
ideas on trying to break the ceiling you
know because
every time you turn around somebody
tries to put a ceiling on top and um
you know shout out to attic for the
diligent work shout out to cog for the
diligent work
shout out for saul for the diligent work
um
today i was just a passenger to be
honest with you and i was enjoying the
ride
um colin is uh first of all he's a jet
fan
when he jumped on you already know from
that point on we were really really good
um and very insightful on a lot of
things shout out to hulk shout out to
undead uh i love those guys
you know they come on hold hogue is
doing a hell of a lot of passion and
undead even though i want you with us i
understand that you you know
bigger and better baby you got to do
what you got to do um
and i respect that but hopefully we'll
get so damn big we can bring you back
yep and pay you
how you're supposed to be paid sir you
know because you know right now you know
we're not making anything
so um but it was a great show today yeah
it was my bad i forgot to call out
hogan and undead man i haven't seen
nothing you're over the moon right now
but home yeah man i love folks insights
and the fact that you know
like he he's on colin's show a lot these
two really vibe wealthy
so it was good to see them on a panel
together yeah i
just want to say that um just you know
but uh 5 p.m i told these dudes i don't
care what day it is
for for for certain guests i i really
actually i don't really care anyway um
i'm going to do whatever i got to do to
make sure that we are successful
period and you know um it was just
it was fun yeah this is this it was
really fun i think i like tuesday no i'm
just easy
i've
tremendous episode super proud of you
guys super proud of this episode
and um just everyone who showed out you
know because at the end of the day
you know what y'all don't know behind
the scenes is a lot of times
you know we'll get oh you can't have
this person on and all this other
nonsense and we're not about that
we've always been like so offset about
inclusion we don't care about your
background ethnicity religion sexuality
none of that stuff matters at the end of
the day if you're a passionate gamer
you know what i mean most likely you can
conduct yourself well and have an
intelligent discussion you'll be on on
the show
so at the end of the day that's what the
focus is and it's kind of funny
because i just got to say this last vlog
is that i saw some people unfollow me
and i thought that was quite
you because of this but at the end of
the day you don't know what the mission
is
you clearly did not listen you don't
listen to the show you know
if you knew what we were about and you
just enlisted the discussion
objectively right this is about love
this is about game this is about
the common bond that unites us so other
than that nonsense i
forget focusing on any negativity this
is great you guys showed out
this was fun salute to colin salute the
whole
you know i mean salute to to undead and
salute to my brothers man we killed that
and at the end of the day i'm proud i'm
proud i'm kidding
no one follows going to stop what we the
mission that we're on you know what i
mean kind of thing we're playing that
click stuff
no one's going to tell the lords what
they can do with this platform we built
this
so that's all i got to say but yeah and
i want to point out that
because of you guys coming here every
week
we have a better success rate than we
did two years ago reaching out to people
like this
two years ago how to reach out to
certain these guests and we got some big
guests for you in the future i ain't
going into that
it's like yeah you know we
it's easier to get them when you have a
community that's like yo we mess with
them and
that's on you guys you guys do that one
last thing i put put the chest out is
that you know
generally when people do come on even if
they don't know who we are
i'm proud that they have a good time and
one of the greatest compliments is when
your peers say yo
i like what you got you guys are doing
you know what i mean yeah and that means
a lot but continue
and then yeah to speak on the chat
quickly again you guys were fantastic oh
they weren't for you
absolutely fantastic we had maybe like
one person in there trolling with
negative stuff and that was shut down
real quick
and again if that person had stated
their opinions in a way that
wasn't combative and and respectful we
have no problem with that
right and if you if you remember that
you can have whatever kind of discourse
you want in our chat without a problem
right but it's all about love it's about
respect facts everybody has a right to
their opinion
mm-hmm that's not what this is about
preaching let's get this super chat
michael aka best side's finest two
dollars super chat quick reminder
playstation's dead
this is my favorite podcast baxter you
sound like commander shepard
yo salud
again thank you guys for pulling up
tremendously you know like i said double
feature this week we
come right back sunday in the lord's day
got another special guest i'm not going
to reveal it just yet
until friday was that was that i do want
to point out that
hold up because i get the food at your
mouth
i do want to point out that we will be
doing a little bit more things in the
future
and um just be looking out for the stuff
like the uh the patreon and stuff
because we're gonna be posting some
stuff in there
you know yeah we're gonna give you a ton
of stunner stuff to eat like attic is
eating right now
we gonna eat two look man i told you my
food is already done look we gone
round see y'all peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
food